Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Aber Amazon wird schon wissen was sie machen, also ich denke mal keiner kann so gut Leute
dazu bringen was zu kaufen wie Amazon, die sind nicht umsonst so groß geworden.
Die Amazonsuche kann es ja nicht sein, die dazu führt, dass man das findet was man braucht,
weil die Amazonsuche findet oftmals nicht das was man gesucht hat, obwohl Amazon das
hat.
Aber der Amazon Empfehlungsalgorithmus scheint so gut zu funktionieren, dass die Leute was
kaufen was sie brauchen, aber noch gar nicht wussten, dass sie es brauchen.
Das sind Staubsaugerroboter oder was ist das?
Vom Namen her würde ich vermuten das ist ein Staubsaugerroboter.
Ja das haben auch ein paar Leute vor ein paar Tagen im Chat geschrieben, dass das wohl irgendwie
taugen soll.
Aha ja, das tolle ist ja, so die Zweitjahreshälfte die ist ja voll von diesen von diesen Sales,
es gibt jetzt irgendwie Cyber Monday, dann gibt es Black Friday, dann gibt es Black Friday
Week.
Ich warte noch darauf, dass die Leute Black Friday Monat oder Black Friday Quartal, bald
haben wir ein ganzes Black Friday Year haben, das kommt jetzt ja alles wieder.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, die tun ja immer so, wenn man bei ihnen jetzt was kauft hat
man am Ende mehr Geld als vorher, was natürlich Schwachsinn ist, aber es hört sich in der
Werbung und wenn du dir das Zeug bei Amazon anguckst immer so an, so nach dem Motto 400
Euro und jetzt kannst du es nur für 120 Euro bekommen.
Normalerweise verkauft es halt auch keiner für 400 Euro, die Preise die Amazoner drauf
schreibt und durchstreicht sind ja komplett random, also hat mit der Realität nichts zu
tun, aber trotzdem, ich meine, wenn man SSDs braucht oder wenn man Amazon Geräte braucht,
ist es ok, vielleicht auch für das eine oder andere, aber wie gesagt, mir wäre es lieber,
die würden da nicht tausende, hunderttausende verschiedene Sachen anbieten, sondern vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger und dann halt ab und zu mal was, was irgendwie wirklich gut ist,
aber sag mal so, die würden das behalten, was ganz gut ist und einfach die 90% Crap
rausschmeißen.
Was machen eigentlich gerade, die Versandzeiten auf Aliexpress, ich muss das mal kurz checken.
Netflix Account Deutsch, Moment, warum sollte ich mir ein Netflix Account auf Amazon auf
Aliexpress kaufen, Sekunde, was ist das, sieht aus wie eine Maus, ist aber keine Maus, ok,
man versteht es nicht, so lass mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz checken, wie denn so die Versand,
ja ja, das ist ja alles Blödsinn, was hier steht, ja, also wie ist denn so die Versanddauer
mittlerweile bei Aliexpress, 12.
August, ja gut, das kommt aus Polen, ok, China, also Aliexpress möchte uns wirklich erzählen,
die Lieferung aus China ist günstiger und schneller als aus Polen, ja, weiß nicht, vielleicht,
wisst ihr was, ich mein theoretisch kann das sein, vielleicht haben die gerade ein Schiff
auf dem Weg und noch nicht alles was in Containern drinne ist, ist überhaupt verkauft, also ich
trau das denen schon zu, allerdings muss man sagen, 10.
August ist halt ganz schön lang und 12.
August aus Polen ist auch ganz schön lang, aus Polen würde ich erwarten, das kommt am
20. oder so, also irgendwie nicht so der Wahnsinn, ja, was, was soll mir dieses Display sagen,
da werden bestimmt nicht drei Microcontroller drauf sein, doch, wait a minute, was, jetzt
blick ich nicht mehr durch, ja, ist ja aber auch so, ist ganz schön, dauert ganz schön
lange der Versand mittlerweile, wie sieht es eigentlich mit den Schiffen in Shanghai aus,
dürfen die Schiffe in Shanghai wieder rein und raus, ich hab das jetzt, ich hab das jetzt
schon eine ganze Weile nichts mehr, nichts mehr vor mitbekommen, schau mal, Shanghai,
Aliexpress, News, gibt's da was, Schiffe, Schiffe, Lieferkettenpralime noch länger gestört,
da war voll auszugehen, Jan, hast du, was ist denn ein Fake ESP-866, ich mein, der ESP-866
ist doch schon China-Chinesen-Kram, faken die Chinesen jetzt schon China-Kram, oder,
was ist da los, Chinesen-China-Fake, das ist ja auf ganz neuem Level dann, ganz einfach,
vielleicht geht der Container ja an irgendein EU-Warenlager und von da weiter, und die liefern
da halt mehr hin, weil der Container noch nicht voll war mit den Bestellungen, und die
faken wirklich, also die Aliexpress-Chinesen faken China-Hardware, also Chinesen faken
China-Hardware, das ist jetzt, jetzt ist aber, ist auch vorbei irgendwann, ne, die sind
ja, die haben davor gar nichts mehr halt, ich dachte, wenigstens ihr eigenes Zeug würden
sie nicht faken, aber ihr eigenes Zeug ist wahrscheinlich zu gut mittlerweile, dass man
es, dass es schon fakebar geworden ist, ja, ich hab irgendwo ein Amazon-Link, aber das
lohnt sich nicht, also, du kriegst ja dann nicht Prozente, du kriegst es gecapped auf
irgendwie 10 Euro pro Stück oder so maximal, also, kauf einfach, ich hab irgendwo einen,
aber das ist jetzt nicht so, brauch ich nicht, aber schön, dass du dran denkst, ja, Silvercross,
das ist eigentlich für den Zap, der China-Chinesen-China-Fake ist das, ja, echt so, ja, das ist gecapped,
also, es gab mal so 2012 rum oder so, da hatte Amazon ein richtig cooles Affiliate-Programm,
da hast du prozentual bekommen, und je nachdem, wie viel du verkauft hast, hast du dann mehr
Prozente bekommen, was ganz nice war, weil es dir auch geholfen hat, wenn die Leute viel
Kleinscheiß gekauft haben, ne, ne, 10% hast du damals auch nicht gekriegt, aber das ging
glaube ich rauf, bis auf, gar nicht mehr, 5, 6% oder so, aber da musstest du wirklich
viel, viel verkaufen, so viel hatte ich nie, das ist eher was für Leute, die halt ganz
viel Kleinkram verkauft haben über ihr Affiliate-Zeug, da musstest du wirklich viel verkaufen, bei
mir war das nicht so, aber trotzdem, du hast halt prozentual gekriegt, das war damals glaube
ich auch noch nicht so, so klein gecapped, mittlerweile ist es glaube ich bei 10€ oder
irgendwie so was gecapped, was du kriegst pro Teil, dass du 10€ kriegst, muss es ja
schon mal was richtig fettes sein, was du verkaufst, das ist richtig teures, von einem Wecker oder
was auch immer, kriegst du keine 10€, selbst kostet ja nur 10€, da kriegst du 20 Cent
oder so, naja, aber immerhin, Amazon Affiliate ist halt insofern ganz praktisch, es kostet
dich nix, es kostet den Käufer nix, es kostet wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal Besos was, weil
die an dem Zeug was sie verkaufen verdienen, also insofern ist es eigentlich ganz gut,
das kannst du passiv einfach mitmachen und wer Amazon bestellt hat dadurch keine Nachteile
und du kriegst ein bisschen was, also insofern ist Amazon Affiliate eigentlich das einfachste
was man machen kann, wo ich gerade erzähle, das einfachste was man machen kann, mache
ich denn überhaupt Amazon Affiliate gerade, glaube mache ich gar nicht oder, nö, also
ja es ist das einfachste was man machen kann, aber nicht, man das mache ich, na toll, also
ich bin einfach kein Stonksverdiener was das angeht, ne du musst das gar nicht selbst
machen, du dropshippst das einfach aus China, das, du dropshippst den Wecker einfach aus
China, das ist Battlefield 4 mit dem Schiff, das war tatsächlich wirklich cool, ich weiß
aber gar nicht mehr unter welcher Bedingung das überhaupt gestrandet ist das Schiff,
das ging ja auch nicht, das ging ja auch nicht jede Runde, ja Hetzner ist gerade noch, ich
wollte ja eigentlich dieses Wochenende streamen, aber wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig mit dem,
ja was wir genau machen und ich habe schon einen Code, aber den gibt es noch nicht offiziell.
Ja diese Primitive Building Videos ist auch so der nächste indische Scam, ich weiß nicht
ob ihr diese Videos auch manchmal empfohlen bekommt, da hast du dann irgendwelche Leute
im Dschungel, die bauen dann irgendwie unterirdischen Swimmingpool, angeblich irgendwie 1-2 Leute
und das ist dann richtig advanced mit Verzierungen an der Wand und sonst was und keiner überlegt
sich ja wie haben die das Wasser da rein bekommen, warum ist das so klar und sonst wie und naja,
also die Dinger finde ich sind so offensichtlich fake, ich weiß gar nicht warum es jetzt so
lange gedauert hat bis anscheinend mal einer feststellt, dass die fake sind, ja und dahinter
steht wahrscheinlich der Bagger, wenn man bei manchen Videos richtig guckt sieht man
so LKWs drinne stehen im Hintergrund, also die sind, das ist einfach richtig, egal es
gibt, der einzig gute Channel in der Richtung ist Primitive Technology, ja das Original,
das ist das Original der Dude alter, das ist der einzige Channel der was taugt in der Richtung,
wahrscheinlich wie gesagt wird mich nicht wundern, also LKWs habe ich schon gesehen
in den Videos, Bagger noch nicht, aber es ist auch definitiv nicht von einem gebaut
wie es in diesen Videos immer ist, es ist totaler Schwachsinn, es ist einfach nur fake
as fuck, so ich refresh mal noch ein bisschen, wer weiß, vielleicht kommt noch irgendwas
gescheites, ansonsten gucken wir uns gleich eine Runde LKWs an, oh man ja stimmt, alter,
ich bin zwar im Ernst, ich kann diese Aufregung um diese ganze Schlagergeschichte nicht verstehen,
ja also ich mein der Text ist sicherlich kein Ausgeburt des lyrischen Genies, aber also
wenn du das verbietest, müsstest du wahrscheinlich auch 90% von Deutschrap verbieten, aber ganz
davon abgesehen, ich glaube das beste, was diesem Typ, der sich das ausgedacht hat passieren
konnte ist, dass das verboten wird, der Typ hätte noch nie so viel Werbung und so viel
Bekanntheit erlangt, wäre das nicht verboten worden, könnte man fast schon vorstellen,
dass das Absicht gewesen ist, ok verboten ist es nicht, es ist richtig, manche Läden
haben gesagt sie wollen es nicht mehr spielen, ich kann es nicht verstehen, dass da überhaupt
so eine riesen Aufregung drum ist, ich mein es ist halt dummer Text, aber was erwarte
ich bei so 0815 Schlager, ich mein die haben alle dumme Texte, das ist jetzt halt ein bisschen,
ja nicht nur dummer Text, sondern auch noch ein bisschen unter der Gürtellinie Text,
aber ich mein wie juckt es, warum juckt das so viele Leute überhaupt, das ist beste Promo
die es gibt, ja es ist echt so, es gibt deutlich schlimmeres, was auch niemand juckt, ich
mein man wird bei allem irgendwas finden was schlimmer ist, aber trotzdem in dem Fall ich
verstehe nicht warum es so viele Leute juckt, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich dass man einfach
mal wieder was hat, über das man sich empören kann, das ist ja eh das neueste Hobby, dass
sich alle empören und dann gehen sie auf Twitter und dann wird dann sich empört mit anderen
empörten und dann ist man ganz furchtbar empört ein paar Tage lang und dann kommt das
nächste Thema, über was man empört ist, Sommerloch, ey immer, dauerhaft, Empörung
ist mittlerweile zweites Hobby von vielen Leuten, sobald irgendwas ist wird überall sich wahnsinnig
empört und besonders auf Twitter ist es ganz besonders ätzend, so dann würde ich sagen
lassen wir uns bei einer Runde Levelcap debaten, was hat er denn, Alter ok, schau wieder, ok
ich predikte mal wieder das Levelcap Video, er erzählt uns jetzt, dass huge changes kommen,
huge changes kommen für Battlefield 2042, das was er uns quasi jede Woche im Video
erzählt, huge changes und irgendwie ganz furchtbar spannende neue Sachen kommen da und am Ende
des Videos fragt er uns dann, ah ne der Reality Mod ist diesmal angesagt, ok, ja da bin ich
gespannt heute Abend 20 Uhr kann man das spielen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass mir der Reality
Mod großartig Spaß machen wird, weil was ich am Battlefield 3 gut fand, fand, war Battlefield
3 und Battlefield 3 auf Squad gemacht, weiß ich nicht ob mir das gefällt, naja zumindest
wird er uns dann am Ende fragen und denkt ihr jetzt, dass Battlefield 2042 einen besseren
Spot ist, das fragt er jedesmal, die Videos sind wirklich immer das gleiche, major changes
genau, ok gucken wir uns das mal an, lass uns mal eine Runde Levelcap debaten, auf geht's,
also bei Modern Warfare muss ich euch ganz ehrlich sagen, ich glaube mittlerweile generell
schon die letzten Jahre über, bei Call of Duty nicht mehr an irgendwelche Leaks, weil
wer soll die denn da irgendwie zufällig finden, es ist ja nicht so als hätten die da irgendwie
einen ungeschützten Webserver und irgendwie der krasse Hacker-Man hat das gefunden und
hat das dann abgezogen und dann wurde es geleaked und dann hoh guck mal da und der Hersteller
sagt nein, das wollten wir überhaupt nicht, dass es rauskommt, diese Leaks kommen immer
zu so günstigen Zeitpunkten, in so günstigen Häppchen, dass ich seit Jahren schon von
ausgehe, dass ein Großteil dieser Leaks schlicht und ergreifend als leakgetarntes Marketing
ist.
Aliens Game ist coming in much more on this week in gaming.
Dataminertempriel has uncovered Battlefield 5 content hidden in 2042's game files, according
to him the AEK, AUG, Bren, RPK, SKS, M2 Carbine, M95 and M249 are all hidden in 2042's game
files.
Die AEK ist Battlefield 3 und 4, die AUG ist Battlefield, gute Frage, die AUG gab es in
Battlefield 3, die Bren das ist BF1, nee BF5 oder, ist BF5, PK ist BC2 und BF3 und wahrscheinlich
auch BF4, das ist BF3, das ist Chinese Battlefield 5, M95 ist BC2 und BF4, das ist BF3, also ja,
Mischmasch.
All scheduled to launch sometime in August, and this isn't the first time he's uncovered
in 2042's game files.
Going to
Copypasted haben, weil sie faul waren. Ich mein, bei DICE kann ich mir das alles vorstellen.
Die haben gesagt, ah wir brauchen mal ein paar Animationen zum testen für den Assault Rifle. Was nehmen wir denn? Ach komm,
lass uns mal kurz hier einfach das Assault Rifle Pack aus Battlefield 4 reinziehen.
Jetzt hast du halt die Assault Rifle aus Battlefield 4 da drin und irgendjemand hat vergessen dort irgendwie das Flag zu setzen, irgendwie
Copy to Build oder so. Der Kram ist halt einfach da, aber der ist überhaupt nicht geplant für das Game.
And then before we get into that, I've got a quick word from today's sponsor.
Man, do I wish I could select my real life hair as easy as I can in games.
Unfortunately back in the real world, two out of three men experience hair loss by the age of 35.
But there is hope if you want to maintain your sexy gaming hair indefinitely.
Wir machen jetzt schon Werbung für
Anti-Aging Haarzeug. Jetzt wird's jetzt, daran sieht man, Gaming ist in der Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen.
...has you covered through the assault provision, keeps them, talk with their expert and while it takes anywhere between 4 and 12 months to start...
...and maintain that smooth gamer hair...
...slash level 50%...
...cap. Alright, now...
Okay, von denen habe ich noch keine E-Mail bekommen. Für die könnte ich aber tatsächlich Werbung machen.
Also, mit meinem real life hair, könnte ich da für Werbung machen, wenn das wirklich funktioniert.
Aber wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
...confirmed on reddit, that the 30mm canons for the stealth helicopters added with zero hour are actually getting nerfed in the august update.
The choppers have proven to be very effective compared to the rest of 2042's air vehicles.
Das ist aber seit Release schon bekannt gewesen und die haben irgendwie jetzt wieder Monate gebraucht da was zu fixen.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, DICE sagt, es arbeitet immer noch ein großes Team und quasi fast komplett DICE an diesem Spiel.
Das ist halt einfach Bullshit, habe ich ja schon öfters gesagt, weil wie gesagt, es gibt die aus, weil sie sind einfach komplett unfähig.
Oder EA lügt uns an und ich tippe in dem Fall mal tatsächlich.
Äh, EA lügt uns an.
...and many players have been requesting a variety of balance changes. Some have suggested removing its ability to drop bombs in stealth mode.
Others have questioned its ability to stay in stealth mode indefinitely.
The new Reality Mod for Battlefield 3 is finally going live this week.
Over 80 players have spent 7 years developing this realistic take on Battlefield.
Ja, da bin ich gespannt. Das ist wie gesagt heute Abend, BF3 Reality Mod.
Heute Abend, 20 Uhr glaube ich.
Ja, 20 Uhr.
Ich werde es mir mal angucken, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das für mich das Richtige ist.
Weil wie gesagt, ich mochte Battlefield 3, weil es Battlefield 3 ist und nicht weil es Squad ist.
Aber gut.
Leute, lasst mal kurz überlegen. Hatte Battlefield 3 eigentlich schon Voice-Over-IP standardmäßig?
Oder musste man das über Portal irgendwie machen?
Nee, nee, das hatte kein Voice-Over-IP, oder?
Standardmäßig. Du musstest das über Xbox Party oder Portal machen.
Hatte BF3 VoIP?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, hatte keins. Aber die haben wahrscheinlich eins, gehe ich mal von aus.
Oder, oder, aber, oder...
Du musst auf den Discord oder so.
Oder auf den TS, oder?
Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob die das reinpatchen können.
Ich meine, es ist ja...
Also diese ganze Venice Unleashed-Geschichte ist ja so ein Aufsatz auf Battlefield 3 mit irgendwelchen Lua-Skripts.
Keine Ahnung, ob man dort sowas wie VoIP nachpatchen kann.
Da bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt. Features und Roadmap.
Die haben tatsächlich Teamchat eingebaut in Battlefield 3.
Nicht schlecht.
Du hast gestern schon gespielt, die haben In-Game-Voice.
Nicht schlecht. Also das musst du erst mal auf die Reihe kriegen, das da rein zu Hackermanen.
Wobei die es wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich in Battlefield 3 eingebaut haben.
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie richtig heftiger Trick, was die da gezogen haben.
So nach dem Motto, es ist eigentlich nur ein zweites Programm, was ein Overlay über dem Game ist.
Oder irgendwie sowas. Ich gehe davon aus, das ist ein richtig krasser Trick.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die VoIP in Frostbite eingebaut bekommen haben.
Aber ich meine, letztendlich ist es wurscht, das funktioniert.
Also ich werde es heute Abend auf jeden Fall ausprobieren, aber nicht im Stream.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken. Wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es was für mich ist.
Aber ich bin gespannt.
Die übrigens nichts mit Battlefield 3 Reality Mod zu tun haben.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass es ein HTML auf. Also der Launcher ist ja irgendwie ein Browser oder so.
Und ja, ich vermute auch, dass es ein Overlay ist.
Ohne dass ich es gesehen habe.
Ich gucke mir das nachher an. Vielleicht gucken wir es uns auch im Stream an.
Aber ich kann halt im Stream nicht in Discord gescheit.
Ich weiß nicht, andere kriegen das gebacken.
Ich habe es auch schon ein paar Mal probiert, aber ich kann nicht streamen, spielen und Discord reden dabei.
Das kriege ich mit meinem Hirn nicht mehr hin.
Ich kann spielen und streamen.
Ich kann Discord reden mit Leuten und spielen.
Aber ich kann nicht drei Sachen auf einmal.
Möb, danke schön für den Sub.
Also das kann ich dann höchstens ohne Discord oder ohne Ingame-Volp streamen.
Oder Ingame-Volp auf leise machen, dass ich halt wenigstens die Leute höre.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das heute Abend wirklich zusammen an.
Säck, Säck, Säck, Säck.
Venice.
Wie sehen da die offiziellen Server gerade aus?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Oh nee.
Fuck.
Kein Schimmer.
Was ist denn jetzt der mehr?
Muss ich nachher raussuchen?
Keine Ahnung.
Keckl.
Doch, aber nicht hier.
Das ist gar keine schlechte Idee.
Ich guck mal auf den zweiten Rechner, ob ich Venice da eingetragen hab.
Ups.
Falscher Knopf.
Venice.
Nein, hab ich nicht eingetragen.
Dann geil.
Ich hoffe, die haben ein Passwort-Reset oder so.
Na ja, schauen wir mal.
Ja, mach ich, mach ich.
Kannst du kurz erklären, wieso ich steige aktuell in das Thema?
Ja, also, ja, kommt drauf an, was du für Themen machst.
Also wenn es um irgendwie Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery geht, da kommt es halt ganz rau an.
Was stellt ihr für Software her, für das du Tools bereitstellst?
Was baut ihr für Software?
Was setzt ihr ein?
Du kannst das zum größten Teil alles mit C-Sharp machen.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, auch Pi ist in diesem Umfeld ziemlich beliebt.
Funktioniert beides, ja, funktioniert beides.
Wenn ihr jetzt natürlich.NET Software habt, die ihr bauen wollt oder deployen wollt oder testen wollt oder was auch immer,
ich denke mal, dann würde es sich anbieten, das Ganze auf C-Sharp-Basis zu machen,
weil die Tests sind dann in C-Sharp programmiert, die Software sind in C-Sharp programmiert,
das Bild geht über.NET, das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, um was es geht, ja.
Also ich kann dir aber sagen, warum ich das bevorzuge, zumindest für so die normalen Sachen, die ich mache.
Das Lichtlichter greife daran, weil ich mehr Ahnung von.NET habe, weil ich.NET schon länger und regelmäßiger verwende.
Und weil ich sagen muss, dass die Sachen, die ich bisher von Python gesehen habe, was wir uns hier auch zusammen im Stream angeguckt haben,
so cool das ist für kleine Sachen und so cool das wahrscheinlich auch ist für größere Sachen,
wo man dann in irgendeinem Container deployen kann oder so, so problematisch stelle ich mir das vor,
könnt ihr mich ja korrigieren, wenn ihr die krassen Python-Checker seid, für so mittlere Sachen.
Zum Beispiel stellt euch mal vor, ihr wollt irgendein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool entwickeln, mit dem ihr,
nehmen wir mal ein aktuelles Beispiel, ja.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ich bastel ein kleines Tool bei uns auf der Arbeit, das kommt auf jeden Server drauf,
das kommt auf jede VM drauf, was Maintenance für diesen Server setzt.
Also mal angenommen, irgendjemand hat im Change-Management-Meeting beantragt,
er möchte jetzt hier irgendwie Server XY irgendwas umstellen und muss den Server rebooten,
keiner will Kernel-Update machen auf dem Server, muss rebooten.
Was bei uns öfters mal vergessen wird, ist, dass die Leute das zwar angekündigt haben,
dass sie jetzt Wartungsarbeiten auf dem System machen, aber sie vergessen das Monitoring auszuschalten für das System.
So, und da wollte ich ein kleines Tool basteln, wo du einfach vom System selber dieses System in Maintenance setzen kannst,
was relativ easy ist. Du brauchst im Prinzip einen Push-Request auf den Prometheus Alert Manager für den Hostname.
Das ist relativ simpel. Und das sind so kleinere Sachen.
Ich wollte da noch ein paar Optionen einfügen, so nach dem Motto, du kannst noch einen Kommentar hinzufügen
und du kannst auch noch die Duration setzen, wann du sowas willst.
Ja, das wäre dann so ein Skript, das heißt dann Maintenance Now.
Da habe ich mir überlegt, ja gut, ich könnte ja mal eine Library für Python nehmen,
mit der ich schöne Terminal-Output machen kann, ja, dass sie schön farbig ist,
oder vielleicht auch Anzeigen in der Tabelle, dass die Maintenance ist.
Sondern da gibt es ja zig Libraries für so etwas. Jetzt ist bloß das Problem, wie bundle ich dieses Skript gescheit,
dass ich das auf unsere Server schieben kann.
So, da gibt es, da gibt es, also das Disployment finde ich bei Python irgendwie ein bisschen eklig.
Vielleicht habe ich auch noch nicht so den optimalen Weg gefunden.
Also, du kannst, wenn du ein einzelnes Skript-File hast, ist es easy.
Und wenn du nur die Standard Library verwendest, ist es auch easy.
Dann baust du das, schiebst das auf das System drauf und hoffst, dass da halt eine...
Ja, nee, so einfach ist es nicht.
Und dann hoffst du halt, dass dort ein Python-Interpreter drauf ist, der neu genug ist,
dass dein Skript läuft mit dem, was du verwendest.
Was wahrscheinlich so ist, wenn du die Standard Library benutzt.
Das ist der einfache Fall, dann ist es gar kein Ding.
Aber ich meine, so ein paar Libraries verwenden ist ja schon ganz nice.
Ja, gerade für Konsolenausgabe, für ein bisschen schöner Formatieren und sonst was.
So, die nächste Variante ist, man macht sich so einen Bundle, ja?
Das Bundle aus allen Dependencies, deinem Programm und einer Python-Runtime.
Dann läuft das...
Moin, schön, dass du den Weg hergefunden hast.
Ähm, wo, fuck, wo bin ich stehen geblieben?
Ähm, ja, genau, also du machst ein, wir gucken gleich weiter,
aber das muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen ausführlicher beantworten.
Und zwar, du kannst ein Bundle draus machen, das ist dann ein Binary Bundle
mit der passenden Python-Runtime, mit deinem Skript und allen Dependencies.
Das Problem bei PyInstaller ist, wenn du das auf deinem System laufen lässt,
dann läuft das nicht zwangsläufig auf den System, wo du das verwenden willst.
Und außerdem kommt ein relativ großes Binary raus,
was du wahrscheinlich auch nicht in dein Git-Repo einchecken willst,
um es dann auf alle Server zu verteilen.
Da ist so ein PlainTech-Skript schon schöner.
So, und du musst, dass das funktioniert,
müsstest du dir quasi einen lokalen Build-Container bauen,
der alt genug ist, dass es alle deine Systeme unterstützt,
auf die du es am Ende deployen willst.
Das ist das schöne von Go.
Ihr habt es gestern gesehen, ich bin weder der große Go-Checker,
noch der große Go-Fan, aber dieses Problem hat Go halt komplett gelöst.
Du kompilierst ein Go-Programm, schiebst das irgendwo drauf
auf ein Linux-System der letzten zwölf Jahre und es geht.
So, also PyInstaller ist dafür schon mal für so kleine Hilfertools
schon mal Hilfertools gar nicht mal so gut,
weil es höchstwahrscheinlich auf deinem Server nicht richtig läuft,
wenn du es auf deinem Desktop mit PyInstaller baust.
Du müsstest dir höchstens auf deinem Desktop irgendeinen uralt-docker-Container nehmen
und es da bilden und dann funktioniert das.
Die ganze Setup-Tools-Geschichte ist auch nicht schön
oder auch das als Wheel-Bauen ist auch ein bisschen problematisch,
weil dann müsste ich quasi wieder...
Weil Wheels sind ja im Prinzip gezippte ZIP-Files mit allen möglichen drin.
Die kannst du dann auf den Server kopieren
und dort musst du dann pip installen machen.
Ja, das wird funktionieren, dann bräuchte ich aber irgendwie...
Das könnt ihr auch nicht in mein Gitrepo einchecken.
Es sei denn, es ist okay, dass man ab und zu mal Binary's eincheckt.
Ja, okay.
Könnte ich einchecken und dann müsste ich irgendwie
Config-Management schreiben, Copy rüber auf den Server
und dann mach pip install Local Wheel.
Ist auch irgendwie doof.
Warum gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit, das zu bundlen als Plain Text?
Vielleicht gibt es das ja, vielleicht weiß ich nicht.
Also warum gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit,
dass man sich einen Ordner generieren lässt,
den ich dann einfach auf den Ordner mit einem Einstiegs-Script,
den ich dann einfach aufs Zielsystem kopiere.
Also in dem Ordner sind alle Abhängigkeiten außer der Interpreter,
der kann vom System kommen drinne.
Und dann ist gut.
Weiß ich, das wäre tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Ach ja, die andere Möglichkeit ist natürlich auch,
dass man einen dieser ganzen Python-Compiler nimmt, die es gibt.
Wie heißt das?
Äh, gibt es auch so zwei, drei,
kommen dann auch Binary's raus, ist auch nicht so schön.
Also gerade für das, wo ich es gut gebrauchen könnte,
irgendwelche semikomplexen Hilfstools für unsere Systeme,
dafür eignet es sich irgendwie nicht so gut,
wobei sich da von der Sprache her gut eignen würde.
Oder ich habe noch nicht The Way gefunden,
wie man das gescheit benutzt in der Richtung.
Das habe ich auch gesehen.
Das habe ich auch schon gesehen, da gibt es PyOxidizer,
oder wie das heißt, ja, in Rust-Binary verpacken.
Das habe ich auch schon gesehen, dass das geht.
Wenn du einen Standalone-Script machst,
dann hast du ja nicht alle Abhängigkeiten dabei, die du brauchst.
Stell dir mal vor, du machst einen Script mit Kommando-Zeilen,
Ausgaben und sonst was, willst du das ein bisschen schöner formatieren.
Und du hast keinen Bock drauf, Tabellen selbst auszurechnen,
wie du Tabellen schön formatierst im Terminal.
Du verwendest irgendeine Library für.
Machst du in deinem lokalen Projekt, PIP install,
ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt,
das Peißen-Gegenstück zu Specter-Console,
das, wovon Specter-Console inspiriert ist,
machst du drauf und gut ist.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist ja gratis dumme, das ist ja gratis blöd.
Rich, Rich meine ich, genau, ja, richtig.
So, und dann hast du halt keinen Standalone-Script,
dann hast du dann quasi deinen Script plus halt die Imports
und in einem anderen Ort die Abhängigkeiten.
Irgendwo.
Weiß nicht, ob ich den Ordner einfach rüberkopieren geht ja wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil die Version so neu ist und die Python-Runtime
auf dem Server nicht unterstützt.
Also das ist irgendwie, weiß nicht, das ist so ein bisschen...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe da noch nicht so die optimale Sache gefunden.
Chronics, danke schön für den Sub.
Nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ich push bestimmt keine internen Tools irgendwie auf ein öffentliches Repo.
Nee, Packs brauche ich auch nicht, Packs sind Zipf halt.
Vielleicht gibt es da auch keine sinnvolle Lösung für.
Ach so, ja.
Ja, aber dann müsste ich das Skript rüber kopieren,
dann müsste ich einen PIP-Install darauf machen.
Das ist alles irgendwie ein bisschen...
Ich will etwas, was ich einfach auf dieses Thema draufkriege.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass ich für ein simples Commando-Signal-Tool
zu Maintenance-Sätzen noch Firewall-Freischaltung und Proxy-Freischaltung beantragen will.
Geschweige denn, dass ich dort irgendwelche PIP-Installs machen will
mit Paketen von der externen Registry, wo dann wahrscheinlich
der Winners-Defender noch rummeckert.
Wir sind im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld, da ist das leider so kacke gemacht.
Du kannst da nicht einfach irgendwas drauf kopieren und ausführen.
Ich finde das auch kacke, aber das geht nicht so einfach.
Da hängt saumäßig viel dran.
Also wenn ich jetzt einfach sage, ich will PIP-Install machen auf dem Server,
das geht nicht so einfach.
Das geht auf meinen Kisten einfach
und das geht wahrscheinlich auf den meisten Kisten einfach,
aber nicht im Business-Bank-Enterprise-Storms-Umfeld.
Da ist mit PIP-Install auf irgendwelchen Server nichts.
Ich komme wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal zum Repo raus, zur Registry raus.
Es wäre wahrscheinlich einfacher für mich, ein Docker-Container zu bauen
und den irgendwie als Tar-File darüber zu schieben
und dort auszuführen, anstatt PIP-Install zu machen.
Oder aber, ich mache es in Go.
Da ist das Binary zwar auch in Binary, aber kleiner.
Oder in Rust oder in.NET
mit einem head-of-time-compiled Binary,
gestripte Debug-Symbols.
Ist das auch nur irgendwie 10 MB oder so groß?
Nee, in C++ mache ich das bestimmt nicht.
Ich will ja immerhin, ich will ja zumindest auch noch
ein bisschen Entwicklungskomfort haben, dann...
Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte da wahrscheinlich
den Wield rausbauen, auf den Server kopieren
und dann PIP-Install-Local-Package oder so machen.
Ich könnte auch JavaScript machen, ja.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Mal überlegen.
Die einfachste Variante.
Wisst ihr, was für mich wirklich die aller-einfachste Variante wäre?
Wenn es die Möglichkeit gäbe,
Single-File-Deployment,
was kein Binary ist.
Also was kein kompiliertes Zeug ist wie PIP-Installer.
Dass der quasi deine ganzen Abhängigkeiten inline
anhängt unter deinem Code oder so.
Was natürlich abartig ist, aber es würde besser
funktionieren, es wäre ein File, es wäre Klartext
und ich müsste es einfach nur rüber kopieren und es wäre da.
Aber ich glaube sowas gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, das ist das Einzige, was ich machen kann.
Ich kann beispielsweise, ich könnte...
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich auch so machen.
Ich mache eine Python-Script ohne.
Ich benutze halt einfach nur Standard-Library.
Ich meine, damit kannst du auch
grafische Konsolenausgabe machen oder so.
Weil ich habe mir überlegt, ich kopiere einfach
auf alle unsere Server, auf alle unsere VMs
ein Skript drauf.
Ja, C++, Alter, MonkaS.
Ich kopiere auf alle unsere Systeme ein Skript drauf,
wo du direkt Maintenance setzen kannst.
Theoretisch würde das wahrscheinlich mit Ansible
auch funktionieren.
Ja, aber nicht vom System aus selbst.
Das müsstest du wahrscheinlich von deinem Host machen.
Von deinem Host kannst du einfach
im Browser in Alert-Manager gehen.
Also das Einfachste ist wirklich...
Du könntest das mit Ansible machen,
aber ich will, dass du auf die Kommandozeile gehen kannst
und sagst dann sowas hier.
Wobei nicht Punkt schlecht, du sagst dann irgendwie...
Okay, ich darf es nicht Maintenance nennen,
weil niemand kann Maintenance schreiben.
Kennt jemand...
Kennt jemand gute Synonyme für Maintenance?
Oder auf Deutsch?
Leute, ich bin bei einer deutschen Bank,
die stehen auf deutsche Wörter.
Sag mal irgendwas...
Wartung.
Jetzt Wartung.
In Standhaltung.
Set down time.
Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich schön.
Nee, wir machen das noch anders.
Wir nennen es down time now.
So nenne ich das.
Das würdest du dann so ausführen.
Oder einfach so.
Einfach down time now.
Und das gibt es dann als einzige Option...
Genau.
Als einzige Option Duration sowas in der Richtung
könntest du noch machen.
Ansonsten, default sind 15 Minuten.
Und...
Das würde ich noch machen.
Ähm...
Man könnte das auch Wartung nennen.
Aber ich glaube down time now
ist fast besser.
So, und dann könnte man vielleicht noch
Minus C machen für einen Comment.
Dass man dann sagt hier irgendwie...
Kackel Reboot.
Oder so.
Okay, was findet ihr schöner, Chat?
Was findet ihr schöner, Chat?
Wir gucken gleich weiter.
Wir schweifen etwas ab.
Was findet ihr schöner?
Down time now
Minus D 2 Stunden oder...
Wartung...
Jetzt.
Wartung jetzt.
Duration 2.
Wartung...
Es müsste Minus Minus jetzt sein.
Komm, wir machen now.
Wir machen now, ja?
Ja, oder...
Wartung Minus Minus now.
Man könnte das auch...
Postchamp.
Das fände ich geil.
Leute, das ist die
Gelegenheit Twitch Emotes
auf alle unsere Systeme zu bringen.
Postchamp heißt das Ding.
Postchamp now.
Das kann sich dann aber dort wieder keiner merken.
Das behalte ich im Hinterkopf, Leute.
Ich bringe Twitch Emotes auf alle unsere Server
und VMs und Azure Kisten und sonst was.
Twitch Emotes.
So muss es sein.
Pause verstehen die Leute aber noch.
Postchamp checken die Leute.
Postchamp checkt keiner.
Postchamp.
Auch irgendjemand der
Wartungsmeister.
Die Wartemeister.
Ich mein...
Für mich wäre bett genau sehr cool als
Kommandozeile, ja?
Aber das versteht wieder keiner.
Aber Postchamp verstehen die Leute.
Weil es ist halt Pause.
Und Champ haben sich die Leute schon dran gewöhnt,
dass ich an meine Tools gerne Champ hinten dran hänge.
Aber ich persönlich würde wahrscheinlich
diese Variante immer noch bevorzugen.
Weil downtime now
können sich die Leute
einfach merken.
Ich mein, man könnte ja now auch noch überschreiben.
Man könnte dann irgendwie
sagen minus S
20 Uhr oder so.
Irgendwie so.
Das ist halt nicht now, sondern
20 Uhr.
Man könnte es auch nennen
Wartungsarbeiten
aktivieren.
Minus, minus,
jetzt.
Nee, gar nichts.
Ich weiß gar nicht wie wir drauf
gekommen sind. Eigentlich waren wir gerade
bei LevelCamp Video gucken.
Und die ursprüngliche Frage war, warum ich
.NET lieber verwende.
Ach hier, ok.
Da hat man noch was geschrieben.
Ich hoffe es ist
ASP.NET Core und nicht wirklich noch
.NET Framework ASP.NET.
Ja, also, wenn
deine Firma hauptsächlich.NET macht,
würde ich sagen, bietet sich das auch an,
das in.NET zu machen.
Weil
ich geh mal davon aus, also ich weiß ja nicht genau
was du machen sollst, also ich geh mal davon aus,
wenn du irgendwas mit
Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery machen sollst,
einer der ersten Schritte ist ja, es
gibt nen Merchrequest, du checkst erstmal
prinzipiell, hat der Typ richtig rebased,
dann lässt sich das merchen. Und als nächstes
lässt du nen Testenvironment laufen
oder nen Container laufen und machst mal die Tests,
die in dem Projekt drin sind.
Die Tests sind in.NET, du musst
nicht zwangsläufig
deine Sachen drum herum
auch in.NET machen.
Aber, ich weiß nicht,
irgendwie würde sich das anbieten, wenn das
.NET Microservices sind.
Ein ASCII PostChamp.
Das ist gut.
Wir machen halt Ausgabe, die erste
Ausgabe ist dann
Echo PostChamping.
Also, ich würde mir auf jedenfalls
die Sharp angucken, allein schon, selbst wenn du das
nicht für deine Pipelines oder
für deine Tests oder für was auch immer,
was du dann da machst brauchst,
zumindest verstehst du dann ein bisschen besser,
was die da eigentlich programmiert haben.
Und das ist ja auch nicht verkehrt,
wenn du ein bisschen
noch für die Infrastruktur und Server
und sonst was zuständig bist, darf ich nicht vergessen,
viele Leute, die jetzt in diesem Bereich
sind, waren früher mal Linux Admins.
Es ist nicht verkehrt zu
verstehen, was da eigentlich drauf läuft.
Ja, also das
schadet auf jedenfall nicht.
Was ich persönlich
an C Sharp und.NET wirklich
sehr mag, auch was ich nicht mag, ist, dass
es von Microsoft ist, aber gut, man ist halt so.
Was mir an dem
ganzen.NET Ökosystem wirklich gut gefällt,
ist, dass Microsoft wirklich
ein richtig
angenehmes Tempo vorlegt
für Fixes und vor allem
für neue Sachen. Die updaten das
öfters mal, wenn was komplett im Arsch ist, aber
sie bringen einmal im Jahr eine neue
Major Version raus, oder eine neue Version
raus. Ist ja auch nochmal
was wie.NET 3.1, aber
ich glaube, aktuell zählen sie einfach durch.
Sie bringen jedes Jahr eine neue Major Version raus,
sowohl von.NET, als auch einen neuen C Sharp Standard.
Als nächstes sind wir glaube ich
bei C Sharp 11 und
bei.NET 7. Das heißt, nächstes Jahr
sind wir dann, nächstes Jahr November,
sind wir dann bei.NET 8. Ich finde, ein
Jahr ist genau der
richtige Zeitpunkt dafür. Zumal
es laufend Preview Versionen gibt
und du kannst dir den ganzen Kram immer permanent angucken,
was es neues gibt. Und
die Features, die sie einbauen, sind jetzt
zum größten Teil auch immer noch
sinnvoll und praktisch.
Als ich gestern
gesehen habe, wie man in
Go beispielsweise
Jason deserialisieren
kann und dort verschiedene Felder
exkluden kann, da musste ich schon ein bisschen
cringen, weil in.NET würde ich einfach
ein Attribut drüber machen mit Jason Ignore.
Ich könnte, ich könnte, ich könnte
den Pause Champ to ASCII art. Moment.
Image to ASCII.
Da gab's doch
für Linux ein schönes
Tool, was das macht.
JPA? Moment, Moment,
das muss ich kurz, das muss ich kurz ausprobieren,
Leute. Ich brauche einen Pause Champ, ich brauche einen Pause Champ
in ASCII Art.
Ich gebe zu,
es hat nichts mit dem Stream jetzt zu tun, aber das muss ich jetzt
schnell ausprobieren. Pause Champ
in ASCII Art.
GitHub. Was
gab's denn da schönes? Image to ASCII?
Hier, ja, was? So was, so was,
so was will ich machen, genau. Image, Image
to ASCII, genau.
Ah. Ah, ja, ja, Fan.
So was, genau.
Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, das mit dem...
Ich brauche einen ASCII, ASCII
Pause Champ.
Deck. Das müssen wir jetzt
ausprobieren. Was?
Bing Image of the Day, irgendwas in Australien
wahrscheinlich.
Werde man in der Physi-Ausbildung viel programmieren?
Nee, das kannst du, was du da in der Berufsschule lernst,
ist komplett useless eigentlich.
Ah, ein bisschen war es wenigstens.
Pause Champ, brauche ich mal das Bild.
Ja, Pause Champ.
Was? Ja, meinetwegen,
auch mal Pauli Lull.
Save Image.
Downloads, Pause Champ.
CD, Downloads,
Image to ASCII.
Yes, Image to ASCII.
Aus dem Auer.
Image.
ASCII Image. Gibt es da
irgendwas fertiges, was mit dem, mit dem
man das machen kann?
Image.
Ja. JP
to A.
Pause Champ.
Leute, da ist er.
Hi-Rez, Pause Champ.
Hi-Rez
ASCII, Pause Champ.
So muss es sein.
Muss man mal gucken, ob man da
irgendwelche Auflösungen
setzen kann hier. With, Hals,
ja.
Minus, Minus Colors
kann das auch.
Oh, guckt mal hier.
Guckt mal hier.
Das ist ja wie original, Alter.
So, jetzt wollen wir hier
Breite.
80.
Nee.
Gleich, gleich 80.
So, nee.
Haha,
ja,
20?
Ja gut, muss, muss man sich
irgendwas überlegen.
Okay.
Eh, guck mal. Guck mal, Leute, man erkennt das sogar.
Man muss halt die Pixel, man muss halt
die Pixel kleiner machen.
Und man kann das bestimmt noch,
man kann das bestimmt noch irgendwie
tunen,
dass es besser aussieht,
Beziehungsweise besser aussieht als so und das dann, der muss kleinere Buchstaben verwenden,
die sind zu groß die Buchstaben.
Nee gut, zumindest, wir haben Post Jam generated als ASCII, perfekt, weiter, so und jetzt gucken
wir aber mal Videos weiter.
Kann man sich nach der Physi aus, du hast recht, das müssen wir noch machen, ja, das
müssen wir, hallo, meine V-M hängt, das müssen wir noch schnell machen, ganz wichtig.
Du musst dich nicht nach der Physi Ausbildung ausprogrammieren, spezialisieren, du kannst
auch was programmieren, während der Physi Ausbildung kommt auf den Betrieb an, wo du
bist.
Nur, dass man das in der Berufsschule lernt, automatisch ist halt nicht so.
Wenn du in einem Laden bist, gerade wenn das vielleicht ein Betrieb ist, der auch schon
viele Sachen in der Cloud laufen hat und vielleicht dort irgendwelche Functions oder du irgendwelche
Infrastruktur automatisieren kannst oder so, dann kannst du auch viel programmieren
als Physi, aber halt standardmäßig, was du in der Berufsschule lernst, ist für'n Arsch.
So Leute, bester Postchamp hier, KappaPride Postchamp.
Ich bin überrascht, wie gut das aussieht, man erkennt das ja tatsächlich.
Minus, Minus, Fill, oh ist das ein bisschen klein, Alter, Hi-Res, Massive, RTX On, ja
Alter, das sieht ja richtig gut aus, das sieht ja richtig gut aus, guck mal hier, das ist
einfach nur Terminal, ok es geht nur mit einem True Color Terminal, aber trotzdem, das ist
nice, ok ich weiß, was bei uns als neues Login Prompt kommt, ne als Login Prompt kann
ich das nicht machen, als Wartungsding und kann ich jetzt noch?
Das ist echt nicht schlecht, das gefällt mir.
So, ok, jetzt aber, Schluss ist, so weiter im Text, ne wahrscheinlich, weil er eine Physistelle
hat und wahrscheinlich, weil er es auch nicht schlecht findet, aber wird gerne ein bisschen
mehr programmieren, also wie gesagt, hängt vom Betrieb ab, oder Avi, warum fragst du,
was ist der, was ist der genaue Hintergrund?
So, aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal Level Cap weiter, also ich bin so absolut null gehyped
auf Modern Warfare 2, ich werde es wahrscheinlich spielen, das ist halt das Schlimme bei mir,
ok, das letzte, die letzten Call of Vanguard habe ich mir nicht gekauft und Cold War habe
ich mir an, doch, ne, warte mal, doch, Cold War hatte ich mir gekauft, Vanguard habe ich
mir nicht gekauft.
Was ist eigentlich mit dieser Modern Warfare, was ist los mit den Modern Warfare Leuten,
warum haben die alle so Pausbäckchen?
Guckt euch die Charaktere an, guckt euch Captain Bryce an, guckt euch Soap an, die haben alle
so Pausbäckchen, was ist mit ihren Modelerstellern los, mögen die das, wenn die alle so aussehen
wie nach Weisheitszahn-OP?
Der Typ sieht aus, guckt euch das mal an, der Typ sieht aus, als hätten sie ihm gerade
die Weisheitszähne rausgenommen, oder, guckt mal, das ist, ok, manche Leute haben noch
fettere Backen, wenn sie Weisheitszähne gezogen bekommen haben, aber das sieht halt schon
danach aus.
Ja, du kannst prinzipiell alles machen, was du willst, denn du musst dich halt dafür
interessieren.
Die Unterschiede, gerade nach der Ausbildung zwischen Physi und Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung,
es ist eh nicht vorhanden, je nachdem in welchem Bereich du bist.
Also, das ist rein, ja, was du gerne machen willst und was du kannst, ja, und natürlich
gerade in der Ausbildung hängt es halt enorm stark vom Betrieb ab, wo du bist, ja, wenn
du jetzt beispielsweise bei einem Rechenzentrumsbetreiber arbeitest, wo du den ganzen Tag im Rechenzentrum
irgendwie Kabel ziehst, ja gut, oder ab und zu Switches konfigurierst, da ist wahrscheinlich
mit irgendwelchen tollen CI-Tools und solch Programmieren nicht so viel, aber selbst
da, ich sage mal ganz im Ernst, also, mittlerweile ist es gut, wenn du in jedem Bereich, wo
du dich, mein Druckerpatronenwechsler mal außen vor, ein bisschen programmieren kannst,
weil, auch wenn du rein im klassischen Systemadministrationsbereich bist, heutzutage hast du viele Server in
der Cloud, du hast viele virtualisierte Server und du hast viel Potenzial, Abläufe zu automatisieren
und Abläufe zu automatisieren schreit ja gerade nach Automatisierung, also sprich irgendwas,
was du programmierst.
Man kann sich jetzt drüber streiten, ja, ob Ansible oder Puppet oder Chef oder was
es nicht alles da gibt, Solstack, falls das irgendjemand verwendet, ob das wirklich Programmieren
ist, aber nach meinem Geschmack schon, ich meine, was ist Programmieren?
Du hast irgendwie Sündags- und Schlüsselwörter, die dann ausgeführt werden und am Ende das
machen was du willst, ja, du hast Kontrollstrukturen wie Schleifen und Ifs und sonst was, also
ja, ist es im Endeffekt.
Ja, googeln musst du eh können, überall, googeln musst du überall können, das ist
eh der wichtigste Skill eines Fachinformatikers, du musst suchen können oder generell eines
der wichtigsten Skills überhaupt in solchen Jobs, ja, das ist tatsächlich so, also Programmieren
beibringen tut dir keiner, es gibt bei den Amis ist das relativ beliebt, dass es da irgendwelche
Bootcamps gibt, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das hier in Deutschland ist, aber ich weiß
nicht, ob sich das, keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen, letztendlich muss man es
eh für sich selbst lernen.
Du kannst, wenn du denn schon ordentlich programmieren kannst, klar, was man sicherlich lernen muss
ist, Zusammenarbeiten im Team, Zusammenarbeiten mit anderen Leuten, vielleicht auch mal das
Lesen was andere programmiert haben bzw. selbst so programmieren, dass es andere lesen können
solche Geschichten, ja, oder dass man vielleicht jetzt nicht um Feature A kümmern kann, weil
Feature B oder Fix B wichtiger ist, ja, solche Sachen lernt man dann mit der Zeit schon,
aber so an sich logisch denken und programmieren lernen, das ist eigentlich zu 90% ja wirklich
Eigeninitiative.
Das ist ja gut, aber das muss ja auch durch Eigeninitiative kommen, ich meine, wenn einer
gar keinen Bock hat, wenn einer gar keinen Bock hat, wenn einer gar keinen Bock hat,
das zu lernen, da kannst du ihm auch so einen Udemy Kurs vorsetzen und damit er nicht allzu
viel haben.
Und dank GitHub ist das ja glücklicherweise einfacher denn je, also wenn du irgendein
Problem hast, was du lösen musst, gibt es zwei Sachen, Stack Overflow und GitHub gucken
und ich finde es auch überhaupt nicht verwerflich, sich da aus GitHub inspirieren zu lassen.
Je nachdem, welche Lizenz der Code hat, kannst du das theoretisch sogar copypasten oder du
lässt von GitHub Copilot copypasten, was dann offiziell nicht copypastet, aber sowas
in der Richtung.
Das ist so, deswegen, ja, du brauchst wirklich Eigeninitiative, sonst klappt das nicht.
Naja, also, das kann ich jetzt schwer einschätzen, ich sag so, wenn man auf was wirklich Bock
hat und sich wirklich dafür interessiert, also ich kann das zum Beispiel schlecht trennen,
also wenn mich jetzt Technik XY interessiert, dann beschäftige ich mich da meistens privat
damit, schon lange bevor man sich damit irgendwann mal vielleicht in der Firma beschäftigt,
wenn überhaupt, einfach weil es mich interessiert.
Äh, ja, den eingebauten, den eingebauten, niemand verwendet was, doch, doch, es gibt
manche Hardcore Leute, die verwenden Dapper, aber den eingebauten, also, also Entity Framework
Core, das ist eigentlich das, was so gut wie jeder verwendet, also, ich glaube, du wirst
feststellen, dass die.NET Standard Library ziemlich gut ist mit der Zeit, Moin, Miss
Apple 80 und, dass relativ viele offizielle Microsoft Packages gibt, die auch ziemlich
gut sind.
Ja, also vieles, was nicht direkt Standard Library ist, sind aber offizielle Microsoft
Packages.
Ja, zum Beispiel Entity Framework, also der offizielle OM Mapper, DB Access Dings von
.NET, ist, glaube ich, ja, es ist keine, wobei doch, Moment, ist Entity Framework Standard
Library oder nicht?
Ist Entity Framework dabei, wenn ich den Projekttyp auf Web Anwendung stelle oder nicht?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, man muss es, ne, doch, Entity Framework ist dabei, was du als offizielles
Package nachinstallieren musst, sind, glaube ich, die ganzen DB Treiber, also zum Beispiel
SQLite oder Postgres oder sowas, ich glaube, die muss, aber das sind auch offizielle Microsoft
Packages.
Ich glaube, die musst du dir über Nougat nachinstallieren oder, ja, runterladen fürs
Projekt.
Das ist kein Ding.
Wie gesagt, sind alles offizielle Microsoft Packages und die tun, also, es verwendet so
gut wie jeder den offiziellen OM Mapper in.NET.
Nennt sich, ah, guck, das da, haben wir sogar ein eigenes GitHub, das da ist der offizielle
Datenbank Access und Mapper und, es ist ein Modern Object Database Mapper für.NET, genau.
So sieht das dann aus.
Ich vermute mal, ich kenne Django selbst nicht, ich meine, ich weiß, was es ist, ich habe
auch schon mal Django Code gesehen, aber noch nie was in Django gemacht.
Ich vermute mal, dass DB Access in Django gar nicht so viel unterschiedlich aussehen
wird zu dem hier.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich denke mal nicht, ja, nee, es ist echt so, also, ich finde, gute IT Fachleute, Experten,
die können alle bis zu einem gewissen Grad programmieren.
Ich meine, ich erwarte jetzt nicht, dass irgendjemand, der sich hauptsächlich um Windows Active Directory
kümmert, dass der Arduino C++ Microcontroller programmieren kann richtig gut, das hat ja
damit nichts zu tun.
Aber was ich von irgendeinem Windows Active Directory Administrator erwarten würde, ist,
dass er PowerShell kann zum Beispiel, was ja auch eine Programmiersprache ist.
Hast du dir das meiste selbst beigebracht?
Ja.
Und ich glaube, das geht den meisten so.
Die Sachen, für die man sich interessiert, die bringt man sich mehr oder weniger selbst
bei.
Das meiste habe ich mir selbst beigebracht, es gibt natürlich ein paar Sachen, die lernt
man im Enterprise Umfeld, ja.
Zum Beispiel habe ich daheim noch nie ein Storage-System angeschlossen, das habe ich
damals bei meiner Ausbildung in Provider gemacht, beim Provider gemacht, weil, naja, du hast
daheim in der Regel kein Fiber Channel Storage-System, was mehrere Tonnen wiegt bei dir, ja, an
der Abstellkammer stehen.
Ja, auch keine, du hast auch keine kleinwagenteuren Loadbalancer im wackeligen Wagen über die
Straße gekarrt, zum selbst beibringen, also so ein paar Sachen lernt es natürlich schon
auf der Arbeit, aber so die ganzen Technik-Skills, muss ich ehrlich sagen, zum größten Teil
habe ich die privat gelernt und konnte sie dann bei der Arbeit verwenden und dort verbessern.
Ja, also ich habe mir irgendwas angeguckt, wie Technologie XY funktioniert und ja, vielleicht
haben wir das Ganze dann auch mal verwendet später auf der Arbeit und dort kannte ich
es dann schon und habe das dann mal praxistechnisch ausprobiert und dementsprechend noch besser
gelernt.
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm, gerade wenn du, das ist nicht schlimm, ich glaube, das ist
fast normal für Leute, die in der Ausbildung sind und sich für die Themengebiete interessieren,
das ist normal.
Du musst jetzt auch mal ein paar Sachen durchprobieren, weil ich glaube, es gibt kein Berufsfeld
oder kein Einsatzfeld, was so vielfältig ist, als das, was du am Ende machen kannst, wenn
du irgendwie in die IT gehst, muss ja nicht als Fachinformatiker sein, aber das kann alles
sein, das kann von Druckerpatronen tauschen sein, bis Cloud-Architektur, bis Mainframe
Kobol, bis Cloud-Entwicklung auf Kubernetes, das kann alles sein, also es gibt nichts,
was es nichts gibt, es gibt nichts, was es nicht gibt dort.
Es kann im Zweifelsfall auch SAP oder sowas sein, also du musst ja schon angucken, deswegen
ist es gar nicht so schlimm, dass du da alles möglich anguckst, was denn ja so dein Gebiet
ist, was dir gefällt.
Dir wird nicht alles gefallen, das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen, also bei mir ist es
zum Beispiel so, ich habe eine riesen Abneigung gegen Windows, Windows Desktop, Windows Server,
Active Directory und sonstige Geschichten, das würde ich für kein Geld der Welt, okay,
vielleicht übertrieben, doch, würde ich, würde ich, ich würde also, das wäre aber
sehr teuer, wenn mich einer als Windows-Admin einkaufen möchte, also ich glaube, das wäre
eher so teuer, dass er das nicht machen würde, aber davon abgesehen, dass ich keine Ahnung
davon habe, also warum sollte er das machen, also es gibt so ein paar Dinge, auf die habe
ich keinen Bock und eins davon ist halt auf jeden Fall Windows-Administration.
Also das ist uns, das ist so Zeug, also generell Microsoft Tools, ich kann es nicht ab.
Wir haben, ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch die, ob ich euch die Geschichte schon mal erzählt
habe, der Felix und ich, mit dem haben wir ja schon mal, mit dem habe ich ja auch schon
mal ein paar Videos gemacht, der war bei mir mit Azubi, der Felix und ich, wir sollten
mal zwei Playcenter-Plates in ein anderes Rechenzentrum bringen, quer durch Frankfurt
und, ja, HS22 oder HS21-Plates waren glaube ich damals noch, sind solche Dinger gewesen,
so sehen die aus, die kamen dann in so ein Gehäuse rein, da konntest du 12, ich glaube
12 waren es, 12 solcher Rechner hochkant stecken und ich weiß nicht, was es gekostet hat, ich
glaube irgendwie 20 oder 30.000 Euro in Vollausbau, irgendwie mit 690 Gigabyte RAM damals, das
ist schon ein bisschen her, also 690 Gigabyte RAM war damals mega viel, ich meine ehrlich
gesagt, 690 Gigabyte RAM ist heute noch viel, überlegt euch mal 2010 oder, nee, das muss
noch früher gewesen sein, 2009 oder so, überlegt euch mal, ihr habt 2009 Plates gehabt mit
690, 2009 96 Gigabyte RAM, das war wirklich richtig teuer, da kamen und wir sollten mal
zwei solcher Dinger quer durch Frankfurt in ein anderes Rechenzentrum tragen, warum hat
man uns das machen lassen, ganz einfach, weil Azubis in die U-Bahn und in die S-Bahn stellen
mit Plates unterm Arm, war halt billig, ich glaube das war der einzige Grund warum man
das gemacht hat, das war halt billig und da sind wir mit den Dingern unterm Arm, ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob jeder nur eins hatte oder jeder zwei, ich glaube jeder hatte nur eins
und dann sind wir in die S-Bahn und standen damit halt rum, die Leute haben uns schon die
ganze Zeit blöd angeguckt, so was haben die da unterm Arm und dann sind wir halt quer durch
Frankfurt gefahren, damals noch in die Kleierstraße, da sind viele Rechenzentren, wir sind in die
Kleierstraße gefahren und mit der U-Bahn, das war glaube ich so 30 Minuten U-S-Bahn
fahren, S-Bahn war es, S-Bahn war es, nicht U-Bahn, ne auch nicht S-Bahn, Straßenbahn
war es, mit der Straßenbahn 30 Minuten quer durch Frankfurt mit solchen Dingern, die sind
nicht superschwer aber die ganze Zeit die tragen sind es auch nicht so leicht, zumindest
das eigentliche Problem war, hat angefangen als wir, also ja ein Plate war ungefähr Azubi
Jahresgehalt, könnte man sagen, eher zwei Jahresgehalte, also der Kram war teuer, ja
so und zumindest das große Problem kam dann als wir ausgestiegen sind, als wir ausgestiegen
sind, als angefangen zu regnen und da mussten wir uns damals die Blades unter die Jacke stecken
und da sind wir wie die, ich weiß, das muss für die umstehenden Leute ausgesehen haben,
als haben wir irgendwelche schwere Bewaffnungen unter der Jacke stecken ja, also wir hatten
ja so richtig Panzerplatte quasi davor unter der Jacke, sind da lang gelaufen und am Eingang
hat dann die Security auch gemeint bei uns, wir sollen mal zeigen was wir unter der Jacke
haben, was habt ihr denn da dabei Jungs, haben wir die Jacke auch gemacht und haben gesagt,
das ist ein Playcenter, also du kommst ja in diese Rechenzentrum nicht so einfach rein,
du musst immer, die haben nicht gelacht, die haben die Jacke aufgemacht und gesagt wir
müssen ins Rechenzentrum und gesagt naja ok, so und bevor du ins Rechenzentrum rein kannst,
du musst ja immer an die Anmeldung gehen, das sind ja meistens Locations, die werden
von einem Anbieter betrieben und der hat dort mehrere Räume wo man sich einmieten kann
und du wusstest dann halt zur Anmeldung, musstest sagen hier ich bin der Max, ich will ins Rechenzentrum
von X, Y, so und so wie der Stock und wir brauchen halt ne Karte oder wie es früher
noch war, beim Provider ein Schlüssel, so oder ein Token zum an die, ich glaube damals
war es ein Schlüssel und ein Token, man hat einen Schlüssel gebraucht für das Gebäude
und man hat einen Token gebraucht für den Raum, irgendwie so war es, so ein elektronisches
Token zum Vorbeiziehen und dann musste man da rein, dann haben die sich das erstmal angeguckt
und dann durfte man da hin, ja das war ein Erlebnis da irgendwie ne Stunde mit Plates
durch Frankfurt zu laufen, ja und der Scheiß war halt wirklich teuer, ja Ticket System,
Abdruck als Ticket System, ok das ist Panes Champ, das ist auch nicht schlecht, Ah wie,
Node.js, Javascript, top zum Einsteigen, äh zum Einsteigen, das ist super zum Einsteigen,
super zum Anfangen, Javascript, Javascript finde ich ist eh die beste Sprache zum Einstieg
weil an Frontend kommst du nicht vorbei, gut mit Node.js kann man auch anfangen, aber an
Frontend kommst du nicht vorbei, ein bisschen HTML, Javascript, CSS muss jeder können heutzutage
und es ist halt dementsprechend auch das einfachste zum Einsteigen, man kann aber auch mit Node
anfangen, warum nicht, dann lernst du gleich ein bisschen NPM Package Management, wobei
NPM halt so ziemlich der Panes Champigste Package Manager ist, es wird nur noch getoppt von C++
Header Files rumkopieren, ja aber zum Einstieg nicht HypeScript, zum Einstieg ist vollkommen
ok direkt mit Javascript anzufangen, da braucht man nicht noch zusätzlich was obendrauf, ähm
ausgeraubt wurden wir nicht, ganz im Ernst, ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass der 0815 Frankfurt
Kriminelle weiß, dass diese Dinger viel wert sind und geschweige denn was er damit machen
soll wenn er sie gekauft, wenn er sie ausgeraubt hat, oh das ist auch nicht schlecht, ich weiß
nicht welche das sind, wieviel Höheneinheiten die haben, gibt es keine Bilder, heißen die
Dinger nicht DL normalerweise, was heißt der, hieß der auch HL, 5, dann keine Ahnung, ähm
ich dachte die Dinger hießen DL, DL 380 und sowas immer, ah Moment war das Dell, Moment
jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch, ne DL 380 ist HP ne, die HP, ja naja, ja das ist nicht
so eh nicht so ohne, wir mussten mal nen Playcenter einbauen, so ungefähr auf Prustebene, Prusthöhe
und dann hochheben in die Schienen, das war auch ganz toll, das sind 8, das war so ne 8
Höheneinheiten Kiste, sowas hier und so ein Teil, baut sowas mal ein, das Zeug ist abfuck
schwer, also das beste was ihr machen könnt, komplett nackig, also komplett raus, Netzteil
raus, ähm Plates raus, alles raus was geht und dann wiegt das immer noch 50 Kilo oder
so, Gachibus Leute genau, das war das Gegenteil von Gachibus, das war wirklich anstrengend,
jetzt zeig mal wie sehen die Dinger aus, na gut 2010 ist auch schon ein bisschen länger
her, war das so ein Tower Teil oder so, ja ist auf jeden Fall, ist auf jeden Fall, gab's
also gerade früher gab's richtig fette Kisten, heutzutage gibt's selten was über diese,
also über 4 HE gibt's eigentlich so gut wie nie, die meisten sind 2 HE, also ich glaub
ich hab lange keine richtig fetten Server mehr gesehen, mal von Storage Systemen außen
vor, ja, aber 2010 ist ja auch schon, ist ja auch schon ein bisschen her, ich rate jetzt
einfach mal ja, also wenn 80 das Geburtsjahr ist, dann war's ja 2010 auch schon ne Weile
da am Start in der Richtung, bin ja auch 1984 geboren, also ich war ja auch schon ein bisschen
älter 2010 und da gab's halt noch fette Kisten, ich glaub das kriegen die Leute heutzutage
gar nicht so mit, wenn heutzutage alles zusammen geklickt wird, so nach dem Motto ja ich brauche
einen neuen Server, ja geh mal in ESX und klick eine neue VM an oder ja geh mal in Azure
und leg ne neue Cloud Kiste an, wir haben damals die Kiste wenn die eine haben wollt tatsächlich
noch eingebaut und ins Rechenzentrum rübergetragen, ja haben wir nicht mehr, also wir haben keine
Plates mehr, wir haben keine Plates mehr, wir haben auch keine Plates Center mehr, ne aber
damals war's echt so, wenn irgendjemand gesagt hat, wir brauchen einen neuen Server, das ist
nicht so gewesen, dass du in irgendeinem Web Interface angeklickt hast, ich will einen
neuen Server, die jungen, das ist so, die kennen das nicht mehr, die können sich das
nicht vorstellen, Leute wenn ihr heute eine VM haben wollt, wenn ihr heute einen Server
haben wollt, dann geht ihr zu irgendeinem Cloud Anbieter, sagt VM, VM, anklicken, next,
next, next, fertig, das war damals nicht so, wenn damals einer einen Server haben wollte,
hat er angerufen bei uns, hat gesagt, Leute wir brauchen ein neues System, dann sind wir
ins Lager mit dem Wagen, ihr kennt sie vielleicht, das sind diese Wagen, die man nicht gesteilt
steuern kann, weil sie die Lenkung irgendwie hinten haben, total wir, wie das ist, und
da bist du ins Lager, hast dein Wagen voll gemacht, bist rüber über die Straße geeiert
ins Rechenzentrum, hast Pech gehabt, weil der Gehweg abschüssig war, dass das dann dir
vielleicht noch runter gerutscht ist, deshalb, dann bist du, ja genau diese Dinger, ja, dann
bist du rüber gelaufen, ins Rechenzentrum, bist rüber gelaufen, bist in den Fahrstuhl,
bist hochgefahren, hast die Rampe runter geklappt, dass du deinen Wagen hochschieben konntest,
dann hast du mit Hauruck deinen Wagen mit Server die Rampe hochgeschoben ins Rechenzentrum
rein, dann hast du den abgeladen und hast den Kram eingebaut, also wenn jemand morgens
gesagt hat, wir brauchen ein neues System und man wirklich gesagt hat, ja wir machen
das jetzt gleich, der hatte das, was weiß ich, 3 Stunden später oder so erst, das hat
schon ein bisschen gedauert, ja den IBM Mainframe haben wir immer noch, aber das hat ein bisschen
gedauert, dazu musstest du dann damals nicht nur den Kram einbauen, du musstest erst mal
Schienen rein machen, also musst du erst mal die richtige Stelle raussuchen, ja, eintragen,
Reckplatz freimachen, Schienen einbauen, dafür musstest du diese tollen Reck Clips
holen, ich weiß nicht wie sie heißen, Clip Clips, nee, die da meine ich, ich weiß nicht
wie die Dinger heißen, da die da, musstest die da holen, diese Server Reck Clip Nuts,
ja und da hast du dir auch gerne mal die Finger eingeklemmt in diesen Dingern, Reck Muttern,
also Eisters anscheinend, Käfig Muttern, seht ihr der Chat, der Chat kennt sich aus, da
hast du dir diese Dinger geholt, hast die erst mal rangeclippst, dann musstest du die Schienen
richtig einstellen, da hast du die Server Schienen rangemacht, hast die Schienen rausgezogen,
dann musstest du dir irgendwie eine vollbestückte 2 HE Kiste erst mal im Zweifelsfall so auf
Brust oder Kopfhöhe heben und das reinsetzen, reinschieben, dann musst du den Kram verkabeln
hinten dran und wenn du den Kram hinten dran verkabelt hast, dann musstest du nebenbei
beim Netzwerkteam anrufen oder wer auch immer da mal zuständig war, man hat selbst gesagt
hier, Port XY wie sieht es denn aus, könnt ihr uns das konfigurieren, da hast du 15 Minuten
gewartet bis die ihre Netzwerkkonfig gemacht haben, dann hast du das angesteckt, ok Link
ist da, dann bist du ins BIOS rein, vorher hast du dir noch diesen hässlichen Monitorwagen
in den Gang gezogen hinter dem Server, wo du danach erst mal alle möglichen Krankheiten
und Erkältungen hattest, wenn du da zu lange gehockt hast, nur vom feinsten sag ich euch,
hast du dich angestöpselt, bist ins BIOS, hast die Management IP Adresse vergeben, hast
sie wieder irgendwo eingetragen, wenn du das gemacht hast, hast du vielleicht dein KVM
angeschlossen, bist in den Technikraum neben dran und dann gab es noch die ganz Hardcore
Variante, Datenbank Server installieren, Datenbank Server wurden damals bei uns von CD installiert,
kein Witz, Red Hat Enterprise Linux, 4 CDs, 4 CDs, Enterprise Linux und unsere Datenbank
Leute damals oder beziehungsweise die Datenbank Kunden des Providers, wo ich gewesen bin,
die waren der Meinung, sie brauchen eine Red Hat Vollinstallation für ihre Datenbanken,
zwar kein Witz, du hast die Datenbanken gestartet und es hat dich erstmal ein Gnome angeguckt,
du hast erstmal einen Gnome Login Manager gehabt, wenn du dich auf die Datenbanken
connectet hast, also per Monitor, Vollinstallation wollten die haben und macht mal eine Red Hat
Vollinstallation mit CDs, da sitzt ihr auch 45 Minuten davor und guckt der Installation
zu, also neuer Datenbank Server 3-4 Stunden, also der halbe Tag, warum, zwischendurch bist
nochmal aus Essen gegangen, also jetzt ohne Mist, Datenbanken einbauen, patchen und installieren
war ein Tagesjob, also das, ok, das war, das gebe ich zu, das waren etwas andere Zeiten,
ich weine der Sache auch nicht nach, muss ich ehrlich sagen, so Turnstuhl-Administration
ist gut, dass es das in dieser Form so weit verbreitet nicht mehr gibt, heute ist es einfacher,
heute hast du ein paar ESX Cluster, machst ein paar VMs oder gehst in die Cloud, machst
ein paar VMs, aber irgendeiner muss die Sachen heute auch noch im Rechenzentrum einbauen,
nichtdestotrotz war das gut zu wissen, ist auch genug vom Kriech erzählt, genau, das
habe ich auch geschafft, wir hatten es auch schon mal, dass die Lüfter in die falschen
Richtungen hatten, weil man die Lüfter rumdrehen musste oder den ganzen Server rumdrehen musste
und so komische Dinge, jetzt rennt man von Ticket, ja ok, es ist ein bisschen anders,
aber früher war Turnstuhl-Admin wirklich, also ich habe, gerade während meiner Ausbildung
habe ich sehr viel Turnstuhl-Admin gemacht, zumal die auch gerne die Azubis in Technikräume
geschickt haben, die haben damals, wir hatten damals bei verschiedenen Kunden hatten wir
so Technikräume und es war so, die Technikräume waren halt mini, dass sie halt Bürofläche
hatten und die haben immer die Azubis in die Technikräume geschickt damals und die Technikräume
waren wirklich haarisch strömend, ja, die Switche hingen hochkant an der Wand und so
was, also die waren nicht sonderlich, also nicht, dass man denkt, da war genug Platz
für den Rack in so einem Technikraum, das war wirklich ganz schmale Abstellkammer, da
musstest du die Switche hochkant hängen, damit sie überhaupt reingepasst haben, so
zumindest haben die damals die Azubis da reingeschickt, weil wir die einzigen Leute waren im Team,
die dünn genug waren zur damaligen Zeit, wobei mittlerweile würde ich vielleicht mit ganz
viel Bauch einziehen, jetzt nachdem ich jetzt abgenommen habe, die letzten paar Monate
wieder durchpassen, ja, weil wir so dünn waren und die einzigen die durchgepasst haben, ohne
dass wir die halbe Verkabelung mit runterreißen, ich meine damals hatte ich 70, 75 Kilo oder
so gewogen, da war das kein Ding, bin ich, da durfte ich mir nichts, ja, ok, so jetzt
habe ich aber echt genug vom Grieche erzählt, jetzt gucken wir mal weiter, wo sind wir stehengeblieben,
eigentlich sind mir die Call of Duty Leaks egal, außer dass der aussieht, als habe ich
die Weisheitsszene ziehen lassen, wieviel hast du von deinem schwersten Stand abgenommen,
13,5 Kilo, es ist jetzt ein bisschen langsamer geworden, also ich habe mich letztens, deswegen
habe ich ja auch schon eine Weile auf Twitter, auf Twitter keinen Wagen Update mehr gepostet,
das hat sich jetzt so eingependelt, es geht aber so ein bisschen minimal, geht das schon
noch runter, aber nix, jetzt nicht mehr so krass wie, ich zeige euch das eine Woche später
und ein Kilo ist weg oder so, so viel ist es so krass ist es jetzt nicht, neuer Zweitkanal,
ich mache ja nix, ich esse ein bisschen weniger fettig, ich bewege mich halt mehr, ja wie gesagt
ich esse ein bisschen weniger fettig und ich bewege mich mehr, ich gehe jeden Tag eineinhalb
zwei Stunden wandern, nicht laufen, weil laufen denken die meisten Leute joggen, ich gehe
nicht joggen, ich gehe wirklich laufen durch den Wald, jetzt bin ich super langsam oder
so, aber auch nicht gejoggt und das bringt tatsächlich was, wer hätte es gedacht, weniger
Kalorien essen und mehr bewegen führt zu weniger Kilo, da hätte man ja überhaupt nicht dran
denken können, wer hätte da nur drauf kommen können, so jetzt gucken wir mal Level Cap
Fighter
Destiny's launch way back in 2014 marked the beginning of the light and dark saga, all
major expansions for the game since then have been leading to next year's final shape
dlc and thanks to a bungee job listing fans know the series isn't going anywhere after
that, the role calls for someone that can work with the narrative leadership to design the
future of the destiny universe, the description also mentions that fans will enjoy this content
for decades to come, some players speculate this may involve more, for decades to come,
wir hoffen das das Spiel auch noch für ein paar Jahre relevant bleibt, decades to come
ist vielleicht ein wenig optimistisch, ach so ja gut, dass die Serie in den nächsten,
das kann ich, wenn die Destiny 3 rausbringen und neue Teile und solche, klar, warum nicht,
aber es hat sich für mich so angehört, als ist das das Destiny, was es jetzt gibt,
denn Destiny 1 ist noch online, aber es gibt halt nichts für, konnte man eigentlich seine
Helden übernehmen aus Destiny 1 zu Destiny 2, a company of heroes, nicht ein Strategiespiel,
aber eine
um eine 12-Week-Standard-Saison mit einem Battle-Pass von 100 Levels zu erzielen.
Leider hat dieses Modell die Entwickler von Key-Bug-Releasern schnell in Gameplay-Empfängern zu verhindern,
da sich große Update in Saisonlaunchen anbieten,
anstatt sie als nötig zu erzielen.
Instead of this seasonal Modell used by many of...
...Bloodhunts-Competitors, it will revert to the classic monthly content update model.
Bugs and issues will be addressed continuously.
Starting with the summer update that launched this week...
...the Battle Pass is being shortened and getting a price reduction to compensate players...
...matches also been added to the...
...game to introduce new players to the Battle Royale's mechanics in a slightly more forgiving manner.
Developers at Crytek have decided to remove the current leaderboard system in place for Hunt Showdown.
According to them, the current leaderboard isn't aligned with their original vision.
It'll be removed from the game with Update 1.9.
But the developers have clarified that a replacement system will be added further down the line.
There's no exact time frame on when that'll happen, but Crytek...
...assured players that they'll keep them updated.
And while players are pleased with the removal of the leaderboard,
some fans wish Crytek would go further and remove the KD statistics entirely.
Many argue that they have no place in Hunt Showdown.
Unless most competitive shooters, Hunt Showdown doesn't have a dedicated ranked mode.
It assigns you a general matchmaking rank based...
Ist das...ist das so?
Wollen wirklich viele Leute KD entfernt haben?
...on your performance and puts you in lobbies with equally skilled players.
The game's current ranking system heavily favors your kill to death ratio.
And while this isn't really an issue at lower ranks, the higher tiers seem to be more ripe with people...
...using almost exclusively the best weapons in the game, while...
Ja, aber das ist doch immer so!
Das ist das, was zu meinem letzten Video passt!
Es wird nur noch geschwitzt als fuck!
Entspannt spielen kannst du nicht!
Was ich ehrlich gesagt doof finde, weil...
...das wegen sollte es einen Ranked-Modus geben oder irgendwie einen Liga-Modus und halt Quickplay.
Weil...
...ich will ja oftmals sogar schwitzen im Spiel, aber dann halt im Ranked-Modus.
Also Bushcamping to just farm kills.
The game is intended to be more of an extraction royale than a deathmatch experience.
Removing the leaderboard and placing a greater emphasis on something like vanishing boss monsters could help improve the general experience.
Star Citizen's developer Cloud Imperium Games just announced a major milestone.
It's amassed a total of 4 million registered accounts.
This year has seen insane growth with in-game events like Invictus and Free Fly Weeks...
...attracting tens of thousands of new players overnight.
The game is currently in a pre-release alpha state with core features and mechanics yet to be implemented.
There's also the long-awaited Squadron 42 single-player campaign that has missed multiple deadlines.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich auch nicht raus.
Das Singleplayer sollte doch schon vor drei Jahren oder so rauskommen.
...starting to shape up into a real game with tons of content to play through.
PlayStation announced a new loyalty program called PlayStation Stars.
It'll begin later this year and will be free to sign up to.
Players in the program complete objectives in-game to earn points.
These points can be redeemed in the store or for other rewards.
Aside from store items, players can also earn digital collectibles.
These include figurines of memorable characters from your favorite games.
Platinum trophies are unique.
However, the first person worldwide to unlock a platinum trophy for a new game will get an exclusive one-time prize.
Es wäre richtig cool, wenn das nächste God of War Output PC direkt kommt.
Weil ich kauf mir keine PS5 nur für ein Game.
New collectibles and awards will be added regularly.
PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds' latest update includes a new map called Destin.
This is the first map released since the game went free to play earlier this year.
Destin is set in a city flooded by a massive hurricane, giving a mix of rich vegetation in some areas and large cities in others.
The town also includes the tallest skyscraper in PUBG history.
Auf der PS4 spiele ich es bestimmt nicht.
Ich habe eine PS4, aber ich habe eine Release PS4.
Nein, das kannst du vergessen.
Das spiele ich bestimmt da nicht drauf.
Also entweder kommst du für einen PC oder ich spiele es halt nicht oder ich warte ein Jahr, bis es auf den PC kommt.
Prices called Ascenders have also been added to make traversing the buildings easier.
The map features new vehicles like the Pillar Car and new weapons like the MP9 SMG and the 012 Shotgun.
A game reviewer on Twitter says that the next Assassin's Creed title will be set in the Aztec Empire.
The rumor was immediately shot down by Bloomberg writer Jason Schrier, who reiterated that the next game would be set in Baghdad.
According to him, the Assassin's Creed title originally started as an expansion for Valhalla, but grew in scope to become its own game.
It's called Rift and will act as a filler until the multi-era Assassin's Creed game Infinity launches sometime next year.
Ja, da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
20th Century Games has teamed up with VR dev studio Servios to create a new Aliens game.
The studio has promised fans an in-
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das letzte Assassin's Creed, was ich gespielt habe, war...
Unity?
Ich glaub, Unity?
Das, was so mega verbackt war zu Release.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, Unity war das.
Danach hab ich kein Assassin's Creed mehr gespielt.
Und die letzten haben mich auch nicht so angesprochen.
Wobei mich das Setting- Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt die Settings cool fand, sowohl für Ägypten als auch Griechenland.
Oder auch England und so jetzt.
Oder was, England?
Weiß gar nicht, Valhalla hat zum kürzesten Mal gespielt, wahrscheinlich England.
Vom Setting her schon.
Aber was mich halt abgeschreckt hat, ist, dass das Spiel sah so nach, das sah so komplett nach Arbeit aus.
An jeder Ecke musst du irgendeine Kiste looten.
Ich fand das bei Unity schon merkwürdig, dass du online-only Kisten hattest und sowas.
Wenn du deinen Account nicht verknüpft hast, gab's keine Kisten an manchen Stellen und so.
Oh ja, das hab ich mitgekickt.
Das ist auch ein Schwachsinn.
Alter, was ein Dummschwätzer.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das ist ein Game-Engine-Hersteller.
Ich weiß nicht was die treiben.
Warum wollen die ihre Entwickler abfacken?
Was ist das für ein Voll-Dap, Alter?
Okay, ich weiß was das für ein Voll-Dap ist.
Der war vorher bei EA und hat's verkackt und ist jetzt bei Unity.
Kein Witz, guck nach, das ist wirklich so.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Voll-Dap ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Voll-Dap ist.
statement came hot off the heels of unity announcing layoffs for 263 employees as well
as a merger with mobile adware company ironsource that company has
nicht nicht nur adware das sind ja auch die die angeblich genau malware verbreitet haben
muss man sich mal vorstellen ein game engine anbieter kauft oder was heißt kauft merged
mit einem anderen anbieter für analytics und adware und wohl auch sachen die als malware
eingestuft sind und jetzt haben sie halt das problem also jetzt was ich mich zumindest fragen
würde als entwickler ist der scheiß in meinem game drin was ich ja persönlich an unreal nicht
mag ist dass es c++ ist was aber für mich egal ist weil ich keine games entwickel software that functions like malware if you've ever gone to install some software on your pc included a bunch of random antivirus software or browser extensions that's what install core does before we move on to our final story of the day let us know in the comments what you think about the battlefield 3 reality mod does the milsim style suit the battlefield series
ich weiß nicht ob ich heute abend im stream angucke aber vielleicht
ich kann ja nicht ich kann ja nicht weil ich bin ich eingelogged
wir können uns in reality mod trailer noch kurz angucken also aktuell sieht es aus wie
battlefield 3 nur ohne hat
und es passiert nichts aber ok es ist halt realistisch da passiert auch nicht laufen was
scheinen vanillamaps zu sein wenn ich mir das so angucke keine neuen maps aber die maps
gerade dlc maps sind ja noch gar nicht irgendwie großartig also die wurden ja nicht so viel
gespielt was das für eine map ist weiß ich beispielsweise gar nicht ja das natürlich
cool das battlefield 3 schon ordentliche zerstörung hatte die musik passt nicht wirklich zu dem
was passiert oder können wir mal eine nome erst mal müssen wir kubernetes stream machen
kubernetes dass man fünf stunden am laufen ist ich denke das hier wird nicht so krass
wie in arma aber aber auch nicht wie in battlefield so reinrennen fünf bis zehn leute umballern
und sterben und respawnen so wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein hat battlefield 3 überhaupt dedicated
server ja mit wenn es hast du sogar server dir selbst hosten kannst ja bin ich mal gespannt
was dabei rauskommt so was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an nein was linux fanboy reviews
mac os ok warum nicht warum warum nicht warum nicht denn du darfst eigentlich für den sub
warum nicht ein linux fanboy reviewed mac os mac os feels old ich fühle mich auch old
hier zeigt man ja ja gut da kann man sich darüber streiten was die auf jeden fall besser
machen als windows und was die auch besser machen als linux ist dass ihre anwendung einheitlich
sind und sie ein einheit also eine ordentliche einheitliche design philosophie haben und
ein ordentlich einheitliches design framework haben für ihr system nicht so wie windows
wurde fünf verschiedene sachen hast nicht so wie linux wo es gar nichts wirklich offizielles
gibt und auch 100 verschiedene sachen das machen die tatsächlich gut wenn alles setzt
sich auch nicht durch keine ahnung ob irgend ein spiel jemals auf metal basiert ist wahrscheinlich
aber gefällt kein sein weil warum sollte man das machen hat unity jemals ein metal backend
gehabt ich keine ahnung zumindest metal jetzt nicht so super verbreitet gewesen easy to
use although a little bit limited so we're going to take a look at how it works with
all the bad faith and all the unjustified criticism that i'm probably going to show das für seine
brustbehaarung sehen in dem video but i can't be accused of though is not telling you about
today's sponsor a fantastic open source keine 36 sekunden im video und schon sehr laut
alter but first a warning i won't be running the very latest version of mac os because i
only own an old big sur man kam denn big sur raus nicht dass es jetzt irgendwie was ist
was sonst waren ok jetzt zwei jahre das ist ok damit sich nicht so viel geändert haben
back pro that was supposed to stop getting updates a while ago was heißt ja ich bin so
als ich niemals die zeit zu versuchen update to monterey so some things might not look
exactly like you want them to still monterey doesn't fundamentally change the experience
apart from the new safari tab bar the ability to move your mouse pointer and keyboard seamlessly
between multiple device desktop itself the much wanted mac os experience let's see how
it holds up you get a top bar and a bottom dock a layout that's now really common and
easily replicated also muss ja sagen gerade gnome hat sich sehr stark inspirieren lassen
von mac os guckt euch den applikations den application ja es ist nicht doch launcher
an unter gnome und guckt euch den art den den finder dings hier an unter mac os also
das sieht ein bisschen anders aus aber es hat schon enorme ähnlichkeiten ja any linux
desktop mac os goes for the global menu which i like if i have to have a menu bar i would
rather it used up the exact same spot on the top of the screen rather than have to hunt
for the menu position on each window i know not everyone enjoys that but i always found
it was the best solution if you had to use menu bars the dock itself just hosts open applications
and open windows for apps that aren't in the dock plus it has the trash can recent applications
and a few nice features you can minimize your windows to the apps icon you can add folders
for quick access to various files or even to your applications if you had your apps folder
to it you can change the minimize effect used automatically hide the dock and you can move
it to any screen edge except the top one moment was für ein ding sekunde rave das ist das
klappt doch hinten und vorne nicht was soll das sein ein bsd desktop auch noch ok da
kannst du von ausgehen dann wird es ja ok vielleicht von der optik her aber ja ich
meine ok immerhin es ist der gleiche unterbau wie mac os das passt mit bsd schon ist schon
irgendwie sinnvoll aber nicht das glaube ich nicht dass da irgendwas sinnvolles rauskommt
keine ahnung wird mich wirklich wundern wenn da irgendwas sinnvolles aber mal schauen ja
take that windows taskbar it also has one very annoying limitation you cannot minimize
an app by clicking on its icon which das ist nicht schlimm ich als tiling window manager
user minimiere minimiere eh nix aber es ist halt kein tiling desktop das heißt da muss
man schon was minimieren
was haben die alle immer
mit aufgeräumten desktops ich verstehe das gar nicht der beste desktop ist ein desktop
der benutzt wird
verstehe ich nicht ein desktop deutlich besser
oder
Ich finde das machen die unter macOS tatsächlich gut, ich meine, guckt euch mal im Vergleich
die Windows-Taskleiste an, wobei Taskleiste kannste es ja nicht nennen, das ist ja hier
dieses Mac, unten ist ja die tatsächlich aufgesplittet, aber ich finde das machen die gut.
Das behält sich auch so, wie ich es erwarten würde, ja, Widgets brauche ich nicht, ja
ich auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, Widgets sind komplett useless, genauso wie, ne, ach, wir haben ja nicht nur
Windows 11, genauso wie diese komischen Windows 11 Widgets, die wird auch niemand verwenden.
Auch wenn sie jetzt hier haben, beautiful Widgets, oder was haben sie bei der Präsentation erzählt?
Beautiful, new, blazingly fast, innovative Widget system, so beautiful und so, ja, Windows
Präsentation.
Tuber Charles Twinkits, PCOM habe ich im Hintergrund laufen, ja, aber nur, um Transparenz
ordentlich zu haben.
Das schöne ist, dadurch, dass die Sachen unter Mac relativ einheitlich sind, wenn
du da Dark Mode einschaltest, dann ist es auch wirklich eingeschaltet und nicht wie bei Windows,
bei manchen Sachen ist es da und bei ganz vielen ist es nicht da.
It's definitely not as powerful as our Linux desktops, which offer a lot more customization
out of the box on KDE, and a lot more options with extensions on GNOME.
Finally, to run applications, you either launch them from the dock, or you have a full screen
app grid with search, that works pretty much like the GNOME app grid.
Ich mein, guckt euch das an und guckt euch den GNOME Launcher an, also wenn das nicht
voneinander inspiriert ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das könnt eins zu eins der GNOME Launcher sein.
It's not bad, but it's not integrated with the multitasking view, which we'll
talk about later, so you can't just drag apps from the launcher to a virtual desktop
to open them, you can rearrange them though into folders or change their order.
Not bad, but also not the best implementation of an apps grid that I've seen, GNOME beats
that handily.
Ne, das ist nicht die Schuld der Programmierer, das ist die Schuld von Microsoft, dass Microsoft
seit 20 Jahren kein gescheites Desktop Framework rausgebracht hat.
Und es ist auch die Schuld von Microsoft, dass du UVP Apps zunächst gebrauchen kannst.
Also ja, natürlich kannst du sagen, warum sind noch nicht alle auf UVP, aber viele sagen,
da ist Microsoft dran schuld.
Bei Apple funktioniert das doch genau aus dem Grund, Apple gibt eine einheitliche Designrichtlinie
vor und Apple stellt die passenden, und zwar die offizielle, AP dafür zur Verfügung so
was zu implementieren und dann funktioniert's.
Und Windows ist so ein Mischmasch aus teilweise noch Windows Forms, WPF, manche Elektronanwendungen,
manche sind UVP Anwendungen, es ist halt kompletter Mischmasch.
Ja, sind Windows Forms Anwendungen dann unter, ähm, Windows Forms Anwendungen haben wir auch
kein Dark Mode einfach, oder guck dir OBS an, oder guck dir OBS an, OBS hat einen Dark
Mode, aber der switcht sich nicht mit Windows oder so, oder, oder hin und her.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich cool, der, die, diese, diese, wie nennt sich das unter Mac?
Ist das der Finder?
Nein, Spotlight ist das, Spotlight ist das, glaube ich, unter Mac, da können die sich
hier bei dieser Windows Suche echt was von abschneiden, die Windows Suche ist absoluter
Müll.
Find ich gar nix, Null, komplett für den Arsch.
Gibt es ein Linux, wo Dark-Light Mode-Switch richtig funktioniert?
Nö.
Du kriegst vielleicht, du kannst vielleicht sowas verwenden, wie äh, wie heißt diese
China-Distribution Deepin, oder Elementary, oder sonst was, die haben das, und da funktioniert
das auch, aber nur, wenn du exakt die vorinstallierten Apps verwendest, sobald du dir was zusätzliches
installierst, funktioniert's schon wieder nicht.
Äh, ich glaube, ich hab meine PyCom-Config im GitHub irgendwo, da, die ist relativ übersichtlich,
und so starte ich's, das war's, mehr mach ich nicht.
Also ich hab ja schon immer Anfälle bekommen, wenn die Buttons auf der linken Seite anstatt
der rechten Seite sind, mag jemand von euch, Leute, was sagt ihr, diese Schließen-Button
links oben oder rechts oben?
Ich, ich kann links oben nicht ab.
Ja, letztendlich ist es natürlich Gewöhnungssache, das stimmt schon.
Das ist auch ne Sache, die mich persönlich an macOS ein bisschen nervt, du hast so viele
Animationen, ich mein, hey, es sieht cool aus, ja, ich sag da gar nix dagegen, guck,
weil man jetzt hier sieht diesen, das ist mir aber zu lang, und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
ich minimiere ja gar keine Anwendung, ja, also was ich mache ist, ja, ist ja schon oft
genug gesehen, ich switch einfach den Desktop, sag so, hier Browser, hier Terminal, hier
IDE, hier sonst was, da wird überhaupt nix minimiert.
Kann man die aktivieren, ja, das ist ja auch das Mindeste, oma, wie lang das dauert, das
braucht ja fast ne halbe Sekunde bis Sekunde, bis das Fenster wieder da ist.
Äh, wieso, machts doch, ja, ok, sag mal so, das ist ja unter Windows auch so, ne, die
Bar hast du ja oben weiterhin, ähm, gut, unter Linux ist es halt so, wenn ich Ctrl F mache,
gerade beim Browser, dann plendet er halt alles aus, dann hab ich halt wirklich, Fullscreen
ist halt da auch wirklich Fullscreen, so.
Wenn du den Alt-Key drückst, dann wird dein Window nicht maximiert oder auf Fullscreen geht,
es wird nur aufgewachsen, um so viel Content wie möglich zu befinden, was wiederum nötig
ist, aber nicht hinter einem Shortcut, der nie erklärt wird.
Alternativ drückt man den Browser einfach F11 und es ist Fullscreen, ne, F11 drücken
einfach, ach, das geht nicht, ok, da würd ich im Leben nicht drauf kommen, dass man
so teilt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich benutze Tiling unter Windows auch nicht, sondern, äh, ich
benutze eigentlich nur unter Linux und damit im Tiling-Window-Manager, wo alles geteilt
ist.
Echt nicht?
Ja, das ist doof.
Ok, das ist tatsächlich doof, aber immerhin eine coole Switch-Animation.
Das heißt schon was.
Ja, den haben sie sich ja damals sogar schon unter COMPETS geklaut, falls noch jemand COMPETS
kennt, da hattest du so auch so ein Exposed-View, ne, wie gesagt, es hat sich COMPETS damals
schon geklaut.
Leute, ich sag euch, COMPETS war auch, also die Zeit, wo COMPETS so richtig angesagt war,
war die geilste Linux-Desktop-Zeit, das war genauso wenig Jahr, das Linux-Desktop, so
wie heute, aber es war wenigstens irgendwie spannend, ja, wenn du Fenster hattest, die
abgefackelt sind oder irgendwie ein Würfel, der sich gedreht hat, COMPETS war einfach
so.
Das wirkt auf mich so, als geht ihm der Punkt wirklich auf den Sack.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein riesen Vorteil versus Windows. Ich meine, Windows hat jetzt auch diesen hässlichen App Store, nur dass da irgendwie kaum was drin ist und der App Store halt... Leute, ich muss euch von meinen neuesten Windows App Store Abenteuern erzählen.
Und zwar, ich hab mir einen Film gekauft oder eine Serienepisode tatsächlich über den Windows Store, weil der Windows Store der einzige Store war, der die aktuelle Folge der Woche hatte.
Und ich hab mir das gekauft, das ging ganz gut, weil das ist mein altes Xbox-Account mit PayPal eingerichtet und so und hat auch nur 2,99€ gekostet und alles okay, alles gut.
Hab ich gekauft und ich mach das Ding an und auf einmal mein Kopf platzt, ey. Das Ding hat einfach maximale Lautstärke, komplette... Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Stellt euch den Battlefield 2042 Soundtrack vor auf maximaler Lautstärke. Also das Ding ist irgendwie mit meinem Audio-Output nicht klar gekommen. Das hat einfach gemacht...
Und das in maximaler Lautstärke, weil mir ist mein Kopf fast geplatzt. Und ich hatte den Windows Sound auf 30%, das war maximale Lautstärke. Und dann hab ich das Kopfhörer abgezogen und nochmal angemacht, das war wieder so.
Und ich musste dann ernsthaft erst Folgendes machen. Ich musste auf Sound gehen, Playback, Digital Audio, Advanced und musste dieses Häkchen hier wegmachen.
Nachdem ich dieses Häkchen hier weggemacht hatte, dann ging's. Nö, Nö, Audio-Codec war alles drauf. Der hatte irgendwie Probleme gehabt mit dem Abspielen, ich weiß nicht wo. Das war ja auch dieser komische Windows-Build-in-Media-Player, also dieses Ding hier.
Nicht der Windows-Media-Player. Der Video-Playback-Player, ich weiß gar nicht wie man den Standard-mäßig aufmacht. Wie macht man den überhaupt auf?
Ich meine nicht den Windows-Media-Player. Die Player-App. Ja, es kann sein, dass es vielleicht irgendwie... Ja, aber dann soll das Ding eine Fehlermeldung liefern und nicht einfach dir das Ohr kaputt machen. Komplett unsinniger Kack, Alter.
Na gut, dass LibreOffice nicht im Apple App Store ist, wundert mich jetzt persönlich nicht. Wie sieht das eigentlich mit Windows App Store aus? Ist da LibreOffice drinne?
Was findest du denn da für ein Scheiß? Die Kohle. Die KohleOffice Suite. Genau die. Die will ich bestimmt haben. Die KohleOffice Suite. Die sieht genauso aus wie das was ich haben will. Moment.
Das ist LibreOffice. Das ist ein China-Chinesen-LibreOffice-Fork.
Die Chinesen, Alter. CoolOffice. Das ist LibreOffice aus China geforkt, Mann. Ist das schlecht, Alter.
Sie sagen ja sogar schon. CoolOffice Suite ist modified vom Open Source Project.
Oh Mann, Alter. Was ein Schrott. Was ein Schrott. Warum ist sowas da überhaupt drinne?
Es gibt Reviews, aber es gibt doch keine Reviews, oder wie? Guck mal. Hier gibt es eindeutig Reviews. See all. Es gibt keine Reviews. Hä? Wait. Nee.
Mein Gott, dieser Store ist so beschissen, Alter. Was ist mit Microsoft los? Die NebulaOffice Suite. Ist das auch irgendein OpenOffice-Fake?
Keine Ahnung. So ein Rotz, Alter. Also der Windows-Store ist da wirklich richtiger Müll. Der Apple-Store ist da deutlich besser.
Und ich sage euch ganz ehrlich. Hackage Management unter Linux. So diese Philosophie dahinter finde ich von allen am besten.
Der Vorteil von Apple ist halt, dass du dir da auch kommerzielle Anwendungen darüber kaufen kannst, die dann aktuell gehalten werden und die sich easy kaufen lassen. Dafür ist es natürlich gut.
Aber es gibt ja immer noch Brew oder Homebrew für MacOS zum Installieren von anderen Tools.
Erstmal Word installieren. Wobei, es verwenden bestimmt viele Word unter Mac, weil viele Leute auch DocX-Dokumente und sowas rumschicken. Doch, doch, es gibt einen Package Manager unter Windows, der ist aber noch ein bisschen, ja, unfertig.
Hat er im Hintergrund die Mario 64-Musik aus dem Schloss?
Nee. Hat sich so angehört. Ja, bei wen juckt der App-Store? Die haben Gaming-Kategorie? Die haben Gaming auf MacOS?
Das wird man im App-Store nicht sehen. Warum sollte Apple im App-Store eine fremde Plattform bewerben? Das kannst du vergessen.
Das wundert mich nicht. Das wundert mich nicht. Wie ist es eigentlich unter dem App-Store?
Nö. Alter, was du schrottest.
Also der Windows-Store ist wirklich Paints-Champ extrem.
Das ist unter allen Betriebssystemen so. Wenn das Ding irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten hat und die gibt es nicht für dein aktuelles System, dann hast du gelebt.
Such mal nach Clipchamp. Ich weiß, dass es das gibt. Da wird ja öfters im Chat gefragt, ob das von mir ist.
Das kommt als nächstes der Snap-App-Store.
Ja gut, das ist ja das gleiche wie unter Windows. App runterladen und installieren. Gut, unter MacOS zieht man die Dinger dann in Applications.
Also viel einfacher geht es doch nicht, oder? Was Peacom geht jetzt bei dir, Pog?
Naja, das musst du dir einmal merken und dann geht's.
Ja, das musst du dir einmal merken. Also so wild finde ich das jetzt nicht. Ja, dann müssen sie das einmal lernen. Also das dürfte doch machbar sein.
Also wer es nicht versteht, ein Icon von links nach rechts zwei Zentimeter zu track und droppen dem ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zu helfen.
Ja, was ist das Problem?
So, MacOS ist nicht ein schlechtes Operierungssystem. Seine Konventionen sind alt, aber funktionieren gut.
Okay, da hat er mich tatsächlich überzeugt, das sah wirklich ziemlich hakelig aus.
Ich hab das ein Stream, wo du Archive Wupplohs gebaut hast. Nee, weil das hab ich nicht gebaut. Das hat da Serious Max gebaut. Ich weiß nicht, ob er das alleine gebaut hat.
Deswegen sag ich es mal, eher plus Mods haben das gebaut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen kann. Ich finde, es ist immer noch mehr aus einem Guss als Windows und es ist sicherlich auch mehr aus einem Guss als Linux.
Das stimmt, Virtual Desktop Handling oder aber man benutzt einen Tiling Window Manager und macht sich um so Sachen keine Gedanken.
Das bei Mac ist es halt so, es funktioniert alles wunderbar, solange du halt in diesem MacOS Apple Ökosystem drin bist. Sobald du ein bisschen was Abweichendes machst, wird es halt schon eklig.
Habt ihr mal beispielsweise versucht, euer iPhone zu back-upen? Das funktioniert teilweise und teilweise auch nicht.
Es gibt mittlerweile einen Fuse-Treiber, also ein Filesystem-Treiber für iPhones. Ich muss teilweise Rebooten dafür, dass es funktioniert. Dann kannst du dann auf dein iPhone per USB angeschlossen zugreifen, auf fast alle Ordner, die drauf sind. Aber schön ist es auch nicht. Also zu Bilder runterziehen eignet sichs.
So, könnte ich MacOS täglich benutzen? Ja, natürlich. Und ich habe es in der Vergangenheit gemacht, als ich ein MacBook für Arbeit hatte und mein vorheriger Job. Ich habe MacOS viel benutzt und ich mag das System.
Aber heutzutage, nachdem ich Gnome und KDE für lange Zeit benutzt habe, sehe ich keine großen Vorteile, die ich wirklich benutzen möchte. Ich denke, dass unsere Desktops heutzutage besser integriert sind, die Features cleverer gestaltet sind.
Und ich bin mir sicher, dass wir, obwohl wir einen super-polischen App-Store oder den ganzen Abstand von Applikationen, die du auf MacOS bekommst, noch besser sind. Und ja, ich würde eher mit Android benutzen, als MacOS. Aber das ist die Entscheidung, die du wahrscheinlich erwartet hättest. Ich denke, unsere Linux-Desktops sind besser ausgedacht.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten. Wait a minute. Der hat zwei Sponsor im Video. Alter. Sponsor, Sponsor, Eingwerbung. Okay, der hat das YouTube-Game durchgespielt, Alter.
Pog. Danke für den Sub. Pog. Chrome OS Flex, schonmal was von gehört. Nein.
Ist der das gewesen? Das kann der gewesen sein, ja. Nee, der nicht Linux-Desktops, der hat Browser getestet und hat gesagt, der kann kein Firefox mehr verwenden und jetzt verwendet er wieder Firefox oder so. Das könnte der Typ gewesen sein. Genau.
Manjaro, genau. Mein Setup auf der Arbeit ist mehr oder weniger das, was ich hier auch habe. Sieht fast genauso aus. Manjaro i3-WM.
Gzip-File-Compression in 100 Sekunden. Nee.
Ist mir jetzt alles zu lang. Leute, in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass wir heute Abend wahrscheinlich Battlefield spielen im Stream, wenn das dann rauskommt und dass ich mal ganz dringend aufs Klo muss, würde ich sagen, ich gehe jetzt auf und wir sehen uns später, falls ich Bock drauf habe.
Ich verspreche nichts, ja. Aber mal schauen.
Nö, mit Manjaro ist alles gut.
Ist halt die Frage, ob du i3 willst. Tiling-WM sind zum Einstieg nicht so, nicht so der Wahnsinn. Also Leute, wir sehen uns, macht's gut, bis denn. See you.